[inaudible].
We good?
Okay,
great.
Oh,
sorry.
Chatting about Kombucha.
I just want to say before this podcast starts,
you fucked up Bell Toro.
You fucked up.
I've been telling everybody that Jimmy Smits the best out there forever and you
let them go.
That's,
that's,
that's a,
that's a huge error on their part.
We can't talk about anything.
It might be like some future news we can't talk about that.
We can put the past is the past is up for discussion.
That's passes up for discussion.
The president's good.
Thrilled.
If somehow or another they were able to work it out where Jimmy Smith was at the
UFC,
we shall see.
That would be what I would like to say.
We shall see how that goes.
I would like to see that.
We will,
that that's a big fuck up.
Yeah,
man.
It was,
um,
well let me say it like,
just a little background.
So lot of people been asking me,
I haven't made any real public statements other than I'm to del Toro Hater.
I just want to say,
yeah,
no,
never had a bell toward here.
Respect.
Yeah.
I enjoy watching it and like the fighters and I've always told everybody that
you were the best out there.
Thank you so much.
Amazing job.
I really appreciate that.
Um,
number.
Well,
yeah,
it's,
it's not a,
it's not a belt with,
I mean,
they were great to work with.
They were great about the,
the whole breakup thing.
Someone say it.
Yeah.
So what happened was I was,
I had a,
a deal with,
with an option year in 2018 was my option here.
And when I was in Verona,
New York doing the Verona show,
my boss sat me down and he said,
we're not going to renew 2018 we want a different,
we wanted different deal.
And when they come to you and say,
we want a different deal,
well if you're on a downgrade,
it's never,
it's never your,
when your girlfriend comes to you and says,
I want to talk,
it's never,
I don't give enough blowjobs that's never,
that's never what,
they never say that it's always going to be a better girlfriend.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's,
it's always bad.
It's always bad.
So,
yeah,
that was it.
When they were like,
we want to change the deal around.
I was like,
okay.
And they did make a like an honors Dev or to keep me,
they,
they really tried,
but they just,
they didn't make an offer.
And that was,
that was worth me coming back.
And that was pretty much a deal.
So it was kind of an amicable,
competitively,
amicable.
It's fascinating to me that in,
in the world of a mixed martial arts professional,
mixed martial arts,
there haven't been that many people that have done you.
What you and I both do,
this is a small handful of people.
You don't,
you,
the weird thing is about our job really in it,
and I mean this from the bottom of my heart.
Um,
everybody thinks they got a guy.
It's,
it's one of those jobs that everybody thinks they can do that they really go,
we'll just throw a fighter and then he'll be able to,
it.
I've seen,
I don't know how many of the unfit they want to do,
you know,
even locker room interviews.
I want to get it next fight.
And you're that and it's,
it's a job.
It's a situation.
It's really,
I mean it's,
it's one of those things where everybody thinks they can throw somebody in and
do it.
And I've seen,
I don't know how many try and it's,
it's tough.
You really have to work at it or having a knack for it.
It's,
it's not the kind of thing that,
you know,
it's almost like coaching.
I mean,
how many times you've heard,
I've heard of great,
great Jujitsu guys.
Like it's just not a great guy.
He's naturally really good.
He's not that good at teaching it because Tim,
it just works and you try it.
It doesn't work,
you know?
That's what I'm saying for a great fighter isn't a great coach,
a great fighters in Australia,
great broadcaster.
It just doesn't work that way.
So yeah,
some guys are just naturally good at it though.
Like for me,
a is naturally fun.
Like when rose number Eunice knocked out,
you want to,
you and Jay check,
he starts yelling thug.
Whoa.
Oh.
Grows like,
that's just pure personality.
Like you either have that in you.
You can't fake yelling out thug rose after rose Nama Yunez Kaos are you.
You can't fake enthusiasm and that's I think real enthusiasm.
Do just a few pages to really care about the sport.
There are two things that that,
well,
three things that we have to do is number one is to educate people.
A lot of people just most American,
it's weird because most Americans didn't grow up wrestling.
They didn't grow up doing.
When we tie that didn't grow up doing Jujitsu.
So a lot of our sport is at least partially we're introducing them to it.
My mom doesn't know the difference between a knee bar and a leg lock.
She knows boxing.
She grew up watching boxing,
so she has a background in that.
So you know,
we have to explain line number two is we've got to communicate enthusiasm.
We're happy to be here.
How great this thing is.
You should want to be here to that.
That's number two and number three is the story.
Every fight has a story and even if we don't tell the story,
we at least give them the option of the story.
Was Buster Douglas always a great fighter and we didn't know it.
Did he have one great night?
Was Mike Tyson unprepared that night?
Was Mike Tyson?
Not as good as we thought it was.
We were literally pops up that in the last podcast,
buster Douglas,
his mom died before the fight and he was just motivated.
Like he'd never been motivated before and got himself in really good shape and
had a mission.
Right.
Galvanized him like crazy.
The death of his mother.
But,
but it's our job to write an antiplatelet makes it more exciting,
you know,
what are we seeing here?
I was saying,
wow,
it's might just having an off night is buster just having a great night?
Was Buster always great and we didn't know it.
There are a million ways to see the story and mostly play by play,
doesn't it?
But we do it every now and then about,
hey,
you know,
this is,
this could be a new thing,
could be an old thing.
And it's our job to tell that story a little bit.
Well,
especially when it comes to results that we think happened and why they happen
in certain fights and corrections that were made,
which is on the technical side of things time,
the worst side of things in the ground too,
which is huge.
And you're one of the,
I mean,
how many guys are doing it,
but you're,
you're a legit Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
Thank you.
Thanks Bridgette.
I think that's important.
Yeah.
I think you have to understand transitions.
You've gotta understand danger.
You've got an understand when someone's doing the right thing and then the
percentages of them getting sub drop substantially with each move you've gotta
be there.
See,
seeing every step of the way going,
this guy's going to bail on this anytime now here comes to scramble,
what would I do?
How do I anticipate this going down and being explained to people so they follow
along and when you do it and I follow along,
it makes it more enjoyable to me.
And that's so mean.
I think we talked about,
I dunno,
you know if we talked about this before,
but I called Dana white about you like how many years ago for lack of trying to
get Jamie Smith hired by the UFC like four years ago,
four years ago.
I was like,
dude,
you want better people?
You want more people?
Yeah,
go higher.
That fucking guy.
Yeah,
I go that guy.
He knows what he's doing,
man.
He knows what he's doing.
He's excited.
He loves the sport.
And I was telling him,
you're a great guy.
And we talk.
He's genuine.
I go,
he's a real fan and he's fucking really good at it,
man.
Go get them.
Really love it.
I mean,
I love the sport.
I love it 100% and know the timing didn't work out then and then now I'm
currently unemployed.
Well,
you got to call some fucking badass fights though,
man.
You know Bella Tours,
welterweight division in particular is God damn stacked right now.
You know what's funny?
There are certain fighters and I was thinking about it as I'm watching the
Cyborg fight last Saturday.
There are certain fighters you meet and it's like stunning.
Certain athletes,
when you,
when you meet Lebron James,
you go,
Jesus Christ,
like I've seen him on TV.
When you see me in real life,
you'd go,
Holy Shit.
That guy's being cyborg is one of those.
Douglas Lema is one of those.
If you ever met him,
when you meet that guy,
you go,
God,
you make 170 pounds.
He's huge.
He is massive.
What do you think?
He walks around at two 10 to tell me that's what he told you.
Let me put these.
So already,
when King Mo fought rampage,
alright Kimbo was to 18 he stepped on scale to 18 I,
so the night of the fight I got,
you know,
Doug scene was there and I walk up to him and I go,
you've walked into a team?
And he goes,
yeah.
He's like,
wow,
I want to eat too much.
I like,
I shouldn't,
but I have,
he has walked around at what King Mo walked around at cause chemo would stepped
on on scale really wasn't cut to make you 20.
I mean cause the,
the weight glasses to 20 when you fought rampage.
He walks around chemo size.
Like if they are the same size that is so insane.
He makes one 70.
He has the worst cut in terms of pounds of herbs.
He deals with it well.
Um,
but he has one of the biggest cuts I've ever seen,
you know,
if he's really good with [inaudible] wasn't under on any ivy and restrictions.
Um,
I,
I think it's by state.
We weren't as a promotion under it,
I don't think.
I think it's by state because I think the hardcore pro testing got instituted by
Usada when Devinsky came along and I think that's when they stopped ivs.
I think states still allow them,
as far as I know,
it's still state for us.
And so what was that?
People don't know what we're talking about.
What that means is,
and this is up for debate because Joe Silva claimed that they had been test
Dunn's.
What he was telling me,
and I believe him that showed that the correct way of rehydrating orally,
I'm actually led to better results over a 24 hour period.
I've heard that,
yeah,
that the [inaudible] thing was good for short term recovery from severe
dehydration,
but to actually go from like a weight cutting weight to go back,
I don't know,
I didn't read any of the studies,
but I do know about the inherent dangers of severe weight cuts,
kidney failure.
You know there's some couple of people that died over the last year,
a professional or a restaurant.
Every,
every few years a wrestler dies down.
A young amateur Muay Thai fighter died Australia.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the issue that people have trouble understanding.
Well first off,
I've,
to the ivy point,
I've heard coaches say it's just for their head day feel better once they like
they think they need the IV and it's like a placebo.
I've had coaches tell me,
it's pretty much a placebo.
You,
you can't do it that much.
One there.
Now,
once again,
I haven't read the studies but I've had coaches told me that that's my provider
just needs it for his head.
It used to be like what we'd assume you had to have.
Like if a guy is going to cut a lot of weight,
it's got to have a guy ready with an,
I mean how many bags did you take?
That was the thing that everybody always brought immediately.
How many bags?
The two things that,
that people don't really know when people ask me,
cause I've been in this since about 2099 is when I first started.
2099 you're from the future and the future.
2099 2009 to 2000 comma 99.
Um,
guys didn't cut like they do now.
And when you look at old UFC is,
and you'll look at the size of these guys,
Tito's one,
a few guys who was now a legit to a five.
Frank shamrock is like my size.
Yeah.
For shamrock was very small for the incredible,
smart,
passionate.
We thought Pete,
when he fought Tito Ortiz and frank shamrock fought,
it was one of the very first displays of defense and and cardio and how critical
it was in victory.
He was lighter,
he was only like one 90 when they fought and he was able to pull the closed the
one 98 Austin while we call it taking stuff out of his pockets.
Like,
like a joke,
like I'm fully clothed.
So guys cut more than they did in the early parts of the sport.
I mean they just cut a lot more.
And when people ask me,
well,
what do you do about weight cutting?
How do we change it?
One of the things about fighting in general,
and this goes to with,
you know,
other aspects of the sport you're asking people who already take a huge risk
finding is just a huge risk period to not take another huge risk.
Just the mentality of if I have to do this twin,
I'm going to do it.
It's,
you know,
you're saying all they need,
they can't take that risk.
Well,
they're already,
you're already have the personality of,
I don't care what I have to do,
I'm getting in that fight and I'm making it.
So it's,
it's,
it's a hard,
you know,
what rule can you make it?
It's hard to do.
You're talking about a group of people that are already used to taking a huge
dangerous physical risks to even get in there.
So adding on the weight cut,
they're going to take that gamble every time.
No,
I know.
It's crazy.
You,
if they can,
uh,
one fc though is instituting some interesting new rule changes and one FC is
doing hydration tests and they,
they've done in high schools now for wrestling that ended up for him.
They should,
they should.
And uh,
who,
God,
I'm trying to remember who told me that this weekend,
but they're essentially saying they're going to be able to band weight cutting.
They're just going to be able to institute that no one's gonna be able to cut
weight.
You're just,
if you,
if you pass the hydration test,
you're not gonna be able to cut weight.
So you have to pass this hydration tested every form at every turn.
You can't just get on the scale and you weigh 170 pounds.
Oh,
congratulations.
No,
no,
no.
You weigh 170 pounds,
but you're in danger.
Like look at your body,
but your hydration level,
are they,
are they testing?
Apparently they're doing it and card falling apart.
Of course not you,
not you.
And then a half the car falls apart.
Yeah.
The wonder what they did.
So when would this,
so that's my question.
Well,
they'd have to do it early and blow all the weight classes up.
Yeah.
That's what we're,
we were having this conversation shift.
Everybody won at least.
Or if you don't even shift them one,
you find out like what?
What?
Wait,
are you really,
you know,
I mean you could be like a Luke Rockhold dude who's a giant one 80 fiver.
I mean,
Luke easily looks like he could be a heavyweight.
He's walking around,
he's like two 20 or two 30 or something like that.
And then he gets to,
I'm,
maybe he's mad at me right now.
I don't really have lean muscle,
not,
I might be exaggerating,
but at the very least when he gets down from,
uh,
down to one 85,
he's probably coming from 200 plus pounds and a big tall two oh five.
But then there's other guys that just don't cut that much at all.
And,
but,
but what,
what gets me is there's no hard and fast body type role.
Like I said,
Doug Summa is huge.
He makes it every time.
Do you ever talk to him about how he does it?
Uh,
he's told me little things cause he used to not do it well and he looked like
death in the last few fights.
He's looked much better cause like,
yeah,
he just,
he tended to boot up to like two 10 to 15 and he's American top team,
right?
Yeah,
they have coconut creek though.
Atlanta somewhere.
Oh real.
It's somewhere down south where he says he might go there and as far or
something,
but he's,
he's not at the main main facility most live there or are they all like a
integrated like Gracie Baha?
Yeah,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
The same team.
So he goes around and get work,
but it's,
it's,
and then I have guys,
you know,
Fernando Gonzalez never makes weight and he looks like he's got something to
lose.
Like he's not the worst shredded,
biggest one 70 and it,
he always has trouble with it.
So it's weird.
Certain guys,
you're like,
man,
there's no way that guy could make it.
He always does.
And certain guys look like they should be.
I'll make it pretty easily and just don't,
it's,
it's strange.
So there's no easy rules what I'm saying.
But they're huge at one 35 huge.
And he made it.
He's a wrestler his whole life.
He makes it every time.
And he's a giant.
Yeah.
I mean like how much of it is discipline?
How much of is a really good game plan and a really good nutritionist like
Cyborg or,
excuse me,
a number of Madoff made weight easily this time.
Yeah.
And you know,
Cyborg obviously had a hard time trying to one 40 but at one 45 she's been
successful.
Like cutting the away.
Yeah.
But for normal amount off.
He said some real fucking problems making 55 this time.
No problems look amazing.
Well,
one of the things,
you know,
once again going back to storytelling for us is when someone doesn't make it,
they don't make weight.
Is it advantage the heavier guy or his advantage,
the guy who if you don't make weight,
maybe something happened that last couple of weeks of camp that maybe it'll
injury kept you from losing the weight or is it advantage of the bigger guy is,
is it better to come in big or did the guy who make wait,
was he a little more disciplined at the end and he has an advantage in the fight
you,
you don't know at the time?
Well,
the problem with Nurburg Madoff obviously was the last fight before this
previous spectacular fight with Barboza.
He didn't make the way because he had to go to the hospital.
So that's a different animal.
That's like you pushed it so far that they were,
they wanted to make sure that you stayed alive,
so they had to bring it to a hospital.
So they obviously realize there's some changes that need to be made.
They made those changes and fucking hell on Friday or Saturday night rather
fucking hell.
Unbelievable.
That was,
it's really weird.
Sometimes when you,
in any sport,
I don't care what it is.
When you see somebody,
you know Jordan in his prime,
you just,
you just can't cover the guy.
It's almost like he's the one on the court.
Yeah,
no number.
Get mouth.
It was like he was the only one in the cage.
It was just,
everything was inevitable.
Everything was inevitable.
Yeah.
It was inevitable.
The beatings were inevitable.
You know,
even if you hit them,
congratulations.
Now you're on your ass getting punched in the face over and over again.
You can't get up.
You're getting mauled brake immediately and,
and it against an excellent fighter.
I still forget Barboza is amazing.
Amazing.
And he made him look like he just,
the look on his face when he got up,
when Barboza was like,
hey,
you were better than me.
I didn't know.
It was almost like a,
yeah,
like a shrine.
I wasn't even mad.
It was just,
when you see somebody that much better,
it's,
it's back to the drawing board.
So I was super impressed with Barboza being able to make it to the final bell.
I mean that was amazing just being able to do that.
That shows you what a dominant performance it was by a guy like Khabib.
But you also realize like what a world class fighter Barboza is that he did,
keeps throwing a wheel kicks in the third round and even landed one of them.
It just didn't have much on an engine.
But fuck man,
he was still trying to win after a horrendous modeling for eight plus minutes.
You don't want,
I really look at fighters when I really,
when I really focus on them,
especially the face in between rounds,
I look for that breaking moment of like,
I,
you know,
uh,
Vito Belfort,
Randy couture,
he's sitting on the ground just like sit on a stool and sat on the ground like
beat and I'm like,
this guy's beat.
It's,
it's,
when you look at them in between rounds and you see that,
like,
what am I doing in here?
That's when you know,
you know the men from the boys mentally speaking and you know in,
in,
in belt where Patricia pitbull and when we fought,
when he fought Daniel Straus,
he's getting beat up for like four rounds every round.
He looked like Lemmy Adam.
There was,
there wasn't any one.
And then toward the end of the fourth round with a rear naked choke,
he just never quits.
And I always looked for that breaking moment,
man.
That's when,
that's when you really,
that's what really separates the guys who are mentally 100% there on those ones.
Those ones,
I think Barboza got beaten,
but I don't think you've got broken.
No,
I don't think so.
If you think about the amount of time during that fight,
he was actually getting his ass kicked.
When I said eight,
a family mindset rounds.
I met minutes.
I think there was like eight minutes of prolonged top time and beating in that
fight.
Yeah.
Plus,
and then there's all the backward movement trying to get away,
throwing those inside leg kicks and doing everything he can,
everything they can to create space.
But for eight fucking minutes,
he never gave up.
We was just,
or whatever it was,
15 minutes could just getting the fuck beaten out of him.
He kept trying to win.
He wasn't capable of doing it,
but he never broke a teddy atlas.
Said,
fighters make an agreement,
I'll stop trying to win and you'll stop trying to hurt me.
Whoa.
Yeah,
and he never did that.
He never went,
let's just go away.
Just like leave me alone and I'll back up and you can beat me.
He never did that.
He kept her on the whole time,
which is incredible,
but just no answer.
How many 10 eights were there on a scorecard like,
well,
the thing is one and one that I attended every round,
it was at least one.
It was the old scoring to then Nevada has an adopted the rules,
so in the for people don't know the new rules make it easier to make
distinctions between a ten nine round,
ten eight round ten seven round.
Which I agree.
You know,
Nevada is not,
that's an old school.
Ten eight yeah.
There was some ridiculous scorecards that it seemed to indicate some of us that
even though the new rules are better and the states haven't adopted them,
the judges have decided to adopt them and some sort of a weird non declared way
cause it does definitely seem there was a much larger disparity in the numbers
and the scorecards.
Yeah but a Nigga man off just,
just Malden,
Malden,
I mean mauled him in a way that you go,
Oh God you're not even there.
He's just on such another level that the odds of you beating him drop so
substantially after the first minute and a half after you get,
you saw the look on Barboza his face and he's like two minutes plus into the
first round and he's trying to get up and you see the look in his face.
He's like fuck,
how am I going to deal with this?
Like this is so next level.
You know what's really funny,
it's almost to me like a throwback kind of fighter in in a sense of,
if you remember back in the day guys that that didn't have a real solid
wrestling or Jiu Jitsu background when they felt that pressure that kind of
went,
oh my God,
this age didn't have any experience with it.
They were just like,
holy crap,
like a truck rolling over you.
You almost will that look on his face like,
oh like I've never felt anything like this and life and for someone training it
proposes level but you know it's dreaming of high level.
Guys are dream with all kinds of outstanding wrestlers in Jujitsu guys to have
that look like this is some crazy pressure.
That's insane because no one has secret techniques anymore.
It's not going to just not divided skill wise.
I mean you'll have great guys in every camp and the fact that you see on
someone's eye,
and I say this to fight as I go,
you don't want the first time you experienced something to be in the cage.
You want to experience this in training and then you can deal with it in the
kitchen.
Barbosa had a look in his eye like I have never felt anything like this in my
mind and that's incredible considering modern techniques.
Well it seems to me that everything right now is his next level in comparison to
a year and a half,
two years ago.
Like dos Anjos beat Robbie Lawler recently and just a fucking Tour de force to
force performance.
Watch that fight.
I was like,
this is as good as Dosantos has ever looked,
if not better,
fucking amazing at one 70 but more importantly like the output,
the f,
the,
the amount of shots that he landed,
the amount of shots that he fired,
the endurance that he's showing everybody is on this complete different
performance level right now.
What I loved about that performance is one thing that generally doesn't change
weight class as well.
When you move up it is power.
Meaning Robbie law,
if you remember at one seven he was not going to read out one 85 he was like so,
so the shot that knocks somebody out at 70 you when you will need to strike
force 25 isn't going to knock out Jakarta.
It's not going to knock out Bob Ballou.
It's not going to knock out these big one any fibers.
So a lot of power punchers have trouble changing weight classes because the
powershot just doesn't go with them.
Dos Anjos looked like he knew that and when I got a volume guys I one 70 I'm not
going to knock anybody out with one shot at at 50 like I did it 55 I have to
throw more at 70 I have to be more accurate at 70 you have to slice them up with
those little ones.
So I like all the adjustments he made for the new weight class.
He didn't try and fight like you did at 55 he's like,
I got to throw more against these guys.
I can't go one punch for one punch with Robbie Lawler is a huge one 70 so I
liked the way his style modified with with the weight class change while lot
guys can do that.
I agree.
And I also think the use of leg kicks is critical.
You've got to slow Robbie down.
Rob is a big heavy guy and he immediately started chopping that.
It is crazy to me also that that low calf Kik is becoming such a giant factor in
MMA.
That kick is just dominant now.
Everybody's using it.
[inaudible] have to do after you knocked him out and couldn't walk on,
he knocks him out and was like limping over to this corner going I you know one
more and I'm done.
That was one of the greatest comeback from behind knockouts ever.
He's,
he's eating all those leg kicks and Melvin is just coming out.
You can see that if folks see it cause it's,
it's awesome.
And Melvin is just owning that leg.
Got a little aggressive as as Melvin Manhoef does and got clipped,
man got clipped with a haymaker Hail Mary makers,
Hail Mary man.
And then one on the way down to,
yeah,
when he was,
when he was out and then boom.
And he goes and Shannon number that Tiki sitting there and lands with a shot.
Yeah.
Robbie was a brutal,
brutal knockout artist.
I always wanted to see a rematch,
but he chained him and Nick Diaz,
I think everybody wants to see that.
Awesome.
How is it possible that that didn't take place?
It's where there's certain matches that,
that you wonder,
how did that not,
you know,
the,
the run Vandelay was on [inaudible] never,
never have,
I mean there's certain ones you can,
man,
I can't believe that.
Find a wrap.
Again,
that's certainly one.
I'm still could that could hypothetically,
I mean,
we still sell like crazy.
I wonder if Nick Diaz,
if he wanted to come back,
would only want to come back for a title fight.
I'm wonder if he's like that kind of money fight guy where it's like,
yeah,
obviously he's got some money and obviously he's not beaten down anybody's door
to fight.
No,
he's not.
You know,
he's doing whatever the fuck he wants to do.
But if you could get him back for a big money fight,
I wonder if it only be like a title fight that's increasing.
What's happening these days.
I mean guys are like,
God,
if I'm not getting the GSP,
yeah,
it came back for a huge money fight and that's it.
You know it's funny.
Dana White said something crazy like a,
yeah,
I was just going to pack up his money and head back.
Check three suitcases to hold all of it.
He did big money fights stuff.
One of the title and then retired.
Yes.
I mean look,
as far as like legacy,
if he wanted to end it right there,
that's a pretty nice cherry.
Yeah,
that's a nice one.
That's pretty nice.
Cherry with a finish.
Yeah.
That's pretty awesome.
Come back up.
Choke the champ asleep and say,
Nah,
I'm good now.
Do you think,
do you think he comes back for any other fighter?
Michael Bisping was the perfect guy for him to come back and fight.
I think these perfect guy from there,
he comes back for Connor.
Yeah,
that's the fight,
but I don't think they want to do that.
I don't think stylistically it's,
it's,
I make,
it certainly happened with certainly sell,
but we know how GSP fights.
Hey,
he's a giant compared to Connor.
He's,
he has a wrestling heavy style.
I don't think it's a,
it's a great team.
I don't think it would be hard for Connor to look good in that fight is the,
I said it,
it'll be hard for him.
Even if he,
it'd be hard for kind of look good unless he,
he caught him coming in,
which no one's been able to really do against GSP.
They would have to do some sort of a catch weight.
Yeah.
Because their body composition would just be so much different.
It wouldn't work if they really did one 70 and you know,
that was an issue that he had with Nate,
but Nate is a legit one 50 fiver.
He kept saying,
Hey,
you got to have some fucking natural boots.
They're like that.
Nate is a big long guy and he does get heavy in between foot.
But the reality is he fought successfully made wa wait one 55 on numerous
occasions easily.
You know,
fought in the ultimate fighter at one 55.
That's his weight.
And that was another one of those one when he came up from 45 55 I think he was
still in that one shot mode.
And if you watch that fight again,
kind of hits some goes shit.
Yeah,
he's still here because I'm at 55 and not only does the US have a great chin,
he's a big 50 fiver.
He's well hydrated.
And especially when they fought,
the first one was one,
one 70.
He's hydrated,
you know,
he hasn't cut it all.
He can take a shot.
And that one shot ability,
he had a 45.
Oh Shit.
It's not here anymore.
I think he was a little bit more prepared.
Didn't Nate?
Nate fought at least twice at 70 in the UFC before he fought Rory.
Rory.
And who else was the other,
uh,
who else?
He fighted 70.
He fought it.
He fought a,
again,
it's seven to forgive we font.
Right now we're being tweeted at someone's,
so
yeah,
totally.
I'm totally looking for that.
I don't remember what it was,
but he had,
I want to say maybe dunk stun gun Kim.
That might've been,
it might've been that somebody is looking it up right now for us young.
Jamie's on the case is that is,
it
was the same way to listed on the thing.
I was like,
well,
put us up so I can take a look at it like we see,
okay.
What does it,
a Wiki kind of just go to the Wiki
MMA record.
No,
show it.
Oh look,
that's there we are.
Two eggs.
What do we got here?
Brian McDonald downtown.
So it was that,
that was right.
So he tried it for a little bit after he beat Marcus Davis.
He just,
just having a hard time taking,
making the way,
and then he came back to 55 and be tacking away.
Go me beat Donald Cerrone.
Beat Jim Miller.
Yeah,
that's Serone fight was,
uh,
that was,
I think his,
maybe his finest fight.
Well,
he took Serone a partner.
He mentally thought fantastic.
Roni with the trash talking and he got,
he got in sorrow in his head and it became very emotional forum where Donald
likes to be friends with the guys.
He fights.
Yeah.
Well that was the DSS is and he can happen.
He um,
he just,
he's a nice guy.
Donald just likes to fight.
He's a really nice but t to loop it back to our earlier discussion about about
weight cutting.
There's a reason guys do it.
I mean,
Diaz is a great 50 fiver is,
uh,
so,
so 70 I,
you know,
a fantastic Bj Penn,
it's the,
the,
to me,
the worst thing ever happened to Bj Penn was when he knocked out Matt Hughes and
thought I can fight at 70.
He was one,
five and one at at 70.
Right.
We choked him out once,
then he knocked him out.
Yeah.
I mean initially when he went to 170 pounds,
yeah.
It was the only,
the only fighter ever beat at one 70 was Matt Hughes and in the EOC.
So what that did is that I think you've thought one of the five,
I'm on the Rock and we've took on crazy.
But yeah,
to Gracie's he fought the hotter ego too.
But once he had that idea that he could beat these guys at one 70 and you saw
it,
Diaz did to him.
I mean,
he just wasn't written.
Rory ate him alive.
It's just a great 50 fiber isn't always a great 70 Robbie Lawler at 70 it's not
a great one.
Any fiber
potentially hard to watch it.
Which you know,
and then was it sort of accentuated back when Bj made his return at 45 and then
you go,
okay,
well this makes more sense.
Yeah.
Like you,
you were at 55 when he fought Diego Sanchez,
who's one of the baddest 55 was a volunteer who was a monster.
But for whatever reason,
he just,
you know,
never quite that,
that level was only attained a few times.
Yeah.
And he,
he's one of those guys were where,
I mean,
I was talking to Josh Thompson recently and we're backstage in New York and you
know,
he's a training with frank shamrock and,
uh,
and uh,
Bj Penn and said they were sitting there with an exercise ball and they'd
already been training for a while and they said,
we're trying to stand on this exercise ball and we're trying to try and falling
and falling.
And BJ walks in like an hour late for practice and it says,
what are you guys doing?
And he said,
oh,
we're trying to stay on sexual as,
and Bj jumped on it and went,
oh,
okay.
And walked back into it.
They'd been trying for like an hour to stand on this thing.
And so,
you know,
I've heard a million stories of,
of that Bj,
you know,
coming in late to practice smoking,
everybody leaving,
you know,
I never trained.
We've got,
I don't know,
but,
but you have that sense.
He's one of those who quote,
man,
if,
if I had,
if you had,
you know,
Bj Penn's ability,
which is off the chart,
incredible with the longevity and work ethic of like a Matt Hughes,
I mean,
he might still be champion.
It's unbelievable what the guy had really unbelievable.
But like you said,
it was in spurts and fits and then he left USC for a while because he didn't
like the money that they got rid of the 55 division and you know,
these fits and starts man that you fucked Machida at heavy scene.
It was over two oh five and over to a fine,
it's a crazy,
but she was like two 10 or some credit fought Duane Ludwig over there.
Yup.
Yeah.
On a triangle.
Choke him out and the rumble on the rock fights were fucking great.
All the gummy fight is awesome.
It's cool.
I love that fight.
It was a great idea.
And he's like,
fuck it.
I'll make my own promotion.
Yeah.
I mean that's ballsy.
And Hawaii used to be a really fertile ground for him.
I mean,
I used to be Ben saveable.
Yeah,
man.
Super Brawl.
Ramona [inaudible] were fucking great back in the day.
If he toward John Hasbro come home fee toward John Huss was over there.
John Lobur him May,
yeah.
May Have had a bunch of fights over there that'd been terminated may him and
that he can anyway member that you getting in your way got mayhem and a crazy
Kimora and they haven't just kept rolling and rolling out of it and wouldn't tab
spanking him and hitting him.
Yeah,
I remember that frank Trigg and Robbie Lawler back then.
You remember in Hawaii Holy Schiller Lawler that's really beat him.
That's right.
Sue may have,
Miller was a bad monster fucker.
Monster frustrating partners.
I started with teen punishment and like 2,900,
2000 and mayhem was there and uh,
you know,
rolling with that guy was crazy.
Super Skillful.
Unbelievably skillful.
Fucking crazy and great cho.
Flexible and everything.
Yeah.
I mean I think is fine as performance skin soccer rabo that's what I think him
is fine.
His performance was like just technical clean and just went through them just
chop,
Bang,
smashed,
choke.
I think he was one of those guys.
Uh,
looking back on it,
there's certain guys who I'm thinking about Josh Barnett a bit,
I think Shaolin a little bit.
Who had they,
he didn't settle down in a promotion right in his prime and really,
you know what I mean?
Cause he's a,
was bouncing around a little bit.
Josh Barnett,
he spent his prime kind of bouncing around a lot,
but at the time he made his UFC Ryan,
he wasn't,
it was late in his career because remember he fought GSP.
It took a long break off and came back and just wasn't the same guy.
You know and and you wonder sometimes I think maybe there's prime vittores shall
end,
might be the best 55 are in the world in his prime.
But he was in Shooto,
he would move around lunch and pan and just was off the u s radar.
And then it was a Kava content too.
Right.
JC,
that was a big issue with him back in the day.
People were saying he was the best hundred 55 pounder alive.
Like a lot of the guys that trained with them,
by the time he came to the states it was just a little bit further past it and
yeah,
there's been a few of those cases,
right?
Like Josh Thompson who were talking about at one point in time was the best
lightweight in the world or one of them and then had some of his best fights
with Gilbert who was also at the same time in the same bracket and they fought
in Strikeforce while they were peaking.
Fantastic fights,
go back,
watch those.
They are awesome guys,
but,
but what people don't understand who maybe are new to the sport,
the ecosystem you could used to be different.
You can make good money and fighting for icon sports in Hawaii,
there wasn't a lot of incentive to move around and guys moved around much
easier.
It was,
you know,
I fought here a couple of times and here a couple times they weren't as
restrictive with talent as it is now,
where it's,
you know,
belter fires don't move over and you'll see fries no more until they're done
with their contracts.
Guys moved around a lot and yeah.
And so somebody like Josh Barnett could move around a little bit more and make
more money.
They wouldn't settling down somewhere,
but it kept him off the radar of a lot of us.
France.
Well,
how about Eve Edwards?
Eve Edwards is probably the best hundred 55 pound in the world.
And the UFC got rid of the division.
I,
you know,
it's so remember that it's hard to explain that to people that they want to cut
the 55 division at the time.
Uh,
he had just knocked out Josh Thompson,
that head kick off the [inaudible] had one of my favorite of all time.
Oh Man.
And uh,
they got rid of three,
five pound division right after that knock.
A write that right in that era.
And once again,
by the time he came back,
he fought in pride.
Beat machine Mo.
Yeah.
Beat machine over in pride.
Last two,
you'll Kim Hansen.
Um,
by the time he came back it was either,
it was just two ladies at the end of the trial,
you know?
Yeah,
man,
he fought hard and Moscow
and Bodog to remember they did got knocked out.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Right here.
Cuts him spinning back fists.
Boom,
boom.
Go through at the same time.
Blood Sports.
Yeah.
That was when eve was at the top of the food chain.
Great Guy.
Well your best stream with him a couple of times when I first started.
I'm super skillful.
Super Nice Guy.
Yeah man.
Um,
so those guys were,
you know,
cut loose.
They had yeah,
they had to go somewhere.
They had to find a,
a place for them and then strike force became the spot where you had the,
the Gilbert,
Josh Thomson Wars.
You had a,
Tim Kennedy had some great fights over there.
That's where he got his start.
When he beat Josh Gould came from there.
Yep,
that's right.
That's when clay beat it.
Beat Josh was a huge,
huge upset.
Yeah man.
There were some good fights over in strike force and they really were like the
tournament format and I was fun.
You know,
the heavyweight division was awesome at a time when the UFC division was,
was at a low point.
The heavyweight division.
Was that a low point?
I thought Strikeforce with great.
Yeah.
It's just hard for people to accept talent levels of folks that aren't in the
big shows.
It's like it took Marlon Mariah's to come over and you know,
look the way he looked in his last fight,
you know,
when you see,
when you see like Justin Gate g come over from world series of fighting and see
the,
the fucking bra he had with Michael Johnson.
Then the crazy fight with Eddie Alvarez realize like,
oh,
this guy has been like this all along.
Yeah.
You know,
and then when Mariah's knocks out aljamain sterling with that,
that will,
he's trying to kick him,
but he hit him with the knee.
But I mean Kales on flatlines them and you realize like,
oh,
this guy is fucking for real.
This is a guy that just beat Hanan Barao right.
Yeah.
Algebra and just be 10 and Barao Mariah's starches him with a high kick and
you're like,
whoa.
This guy was in the world series of fighting.
People didn't really look at that.
It's like he's top shelf talent.
When Eddie came from elsewhere,
Yup.
He comes over,
he goes in and you could argue,
you could argue that Eddie was in his physical prime bells was a little bit
younger,
a little bit sharper.
He comes over to the UFC,
does the same thing,
knocks people out,
one's a belt and suddenly he's on everybody's radar.
I said,
well,
you know,
he was pretty memory loss of Donald first.
Yeah,
he did.
He did.
Donald duck expose the weaknesses to let kids.
Yeah.
That was one of Donald's best fights.
When you think about what Eddy went through,
when you go cowboy Soroti,
that one's Gilbert Melendez was next for him though.
San Joe's.
It was like Jesus Christ as a murderer's on.
Yup.
And The dos Anjos Kao is just crazy.
Eddie always is.
He's always going to have power.
Savage.
He's a fun fucking dude to watch and he gets dropped in like almost every fight.
He's saying it was just like a thing,
like what does anything to get drop.
Boom.
And he gets up.
He keeps finding,
it's almost like they'd wakes him up.
Well,
he's just so ferocious guy too.
He's a great guy.
He's so ferocious that it's almost inevitable that he's going to get tagged.
Yeah.
Because he's just so like thrown it all to the wind.
Let's see.
Let's find out.
He's confident that he can get through it better than you can.
Just like everybody's going to get cracked.
Like that's why the gauge you fight was so engaging.
Like you knew this is what this fight was going to be.
And it
was one of the rare fights that 100% lived up to the hype.
Yeah.
It was exactly what we thought it was going to be.
It was fucking madness from the beginning to the end.
And when you look at how many,
some of you listen to how many champs from different organizations,
he's beaten in his career and he's beaten them all.
Yeah.
He's beaten them all.
You know,
cause he was one of those guys.
Once again,
going back to what were talking about where he moved around a lot in his prime
and you went from Japan to Beltone was awful.
Lot of fans radars.
He was like,
uh,
like that.
The,
you know,
the,
the people that really follow him,
the man knew Eddie Alvarez,
but you're a casual fan.
Didn't until he made his UFC trends.
Is he the only guy that ever won the title in both organizations?
They'll turn you off,
say yeah.
Uh,
yes.
Yeah.
Right.
No one else has.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's pretty God.
Damn impressive.
That's incredible.
I think the other guy was a chances Lima or Rory,
depending upon who wins that fight.
Yeah.
The winner of that fight is write down what they,
right there,
right there with everybody.
I mean,
you can't deny it.
Rory beat Tyron in a very dominant decision.
Completely.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he's lost the guys.
He lost the Lawler and of course Lawler got knocked out by tire and so he can't
do MMA.
Math doesn't work,
but Tyrons the champ and Roy beat him like,
that's,
there's no eminent man.
He's there.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I think Tyron is better now.
I really do.
Yeah,
definitely.
100% and you know,
maybe it'd be different if they fought again,
but it's just statistically interesting.
He says the things when I talked to him when he came over to [inaudible],
I,
you know,
it's funny,
we do fighter fighter meetings fighting or interviews where I sit them down and
I talked to him about the upcoming fights and everything and I don't pay
attention to what they say as much as how they say it.
And I have to say weren't Mcdonald when he came in,
I went,
this guy wants to be champion.
He's not,
he's not coming over here going,
I'm going to get paid.
And that's what I mean.
He really has a fire in him to be champion.
He is 100% devoted to it and uh,
that puts them in rare air and Lima,
if you haven't seen that guy,
fine man,
I,
he hits you,
you don't know where you are.
He is fun.
He puts everything behind every punch and he can start to anybody in the
division.
The question means,
can you handle the take down?
His take down defense has been suspect in the past and we'll see if he can
handle it and take down over.
Yeah,
because that's exactly what Rory used on Paul Dale and he just went right
through Paul Daley.
Any cracked him for it?
That's what the is.
He cracked him and it kind of made daily hesitating.
Then boom,
take down some missions.
Yeah,
you could see that he,
he wanted to let deal,
he know this is a fight.
I'm going to,
I'm going to be a danger on the feet standing and then guess what?
Oh look,
I'm on the ground.
I'm not afraid.
I'm the for you and now you're getting strangled.
Yeah.
As long as he's not afraid of him standing up,
then there's no hesitancy in engaging and he wasn't a for,
I mean he's the one who drew,
I mean he's the one lens first.
He's top of the food chain in my opinion,
I think.
I think he's right up there with anybody at 170 pounds in the world.
And I'd like to see him back in the UFC for selfish reasons.
Of course you don't understand.
And I want to see what the fuck is going to happen now.
I mean,
the whole division,
it's a topsy turvy right now.
Yeah,
no one 55 and one 70 it's all craziness.
This is,
so,
there's so much happening right now with RDA just dominating Robbie Lawler like
that.
And people clamoring for a title fight for him.
And now Tyron had to get shoulder surgery.
So Tyron had a toward labor room,
apparently tried to rehab it and eventually wound up getting surgery.
So he's out for several months,
you know,
where he can't do shit.
A tough thing whenever he belt or the sea or wherever.
Whenever you have that backlog,
whenever you have a champion,
can't defend the title or something like that.
Or He's out for a little bit.
And the Puranas.
I mean they eat each other,
you know,
if there's no,
oh,
we're gonna get the title.
You can go through your prime waiting for that guy to come back from surgery
like a year.
I said like my,
whatever it is in a division that's that stacked and these guys are killers.
You can go through your whole prime trying to climb up that mountain again.
It is tough.
That's it.
It's generic boxing and MMA.
Right?
Because in boxing the your manager would make you keep that number one contender
position.
Hundred percent.
Yeah,
they would.
They would wait on that one.
Let's wait on this one.
But we want to take a risk or you'd fight nobody's,
yeah,
you find some Joe Louis Bum of the month club that was thinking about boxing.
Yeah.
Guys would take warmup,
fights,
tune up fights.
Yeah.
And those would also be like highlight fights because you know,
you tee off on some guy that was below him and everybody gets super excited
about this guy that Tyson's about to fight or whatever it was.
Yeah.
No,
it's funny.
I was talking to Steve,
I told you to talk to Steve Hardwick today actually.
We ended up chatting a little bit.
He does the boxing for showtime.
He's the unofficial score.
That guy used to be editor for ring magazine for like 30 years.
You can't stump him about boxing Adeline slide.
I that as some obscure stuff.
He is phenomenal.
Everything he knows.
We were talking once about the heavyweight division and Oh,
it's not really good right now,
and he looked at me.
He goes,
it usually isn't.
He said the the heavily division usually isn't the most stack division in
boxing.
We remember the errors when it was because that really stands out to us,
but generally it's not that good.
Usually 47 is the marquee division with great fighters in it.
He's like,
the reason Tyson stands out so much is you talk about all,
there was nobody who to fight in the 80s well,
they're usually what their whole decades where you aren't that good.
You know,
it happens all the time.
Tubs as a champ.
Yeah.
There was a lot of guys,
Tony Tucker,
remember him?
Sure.
There was a lot of guys,
uh,
post,
Larry Holmes.
Yeah.
Just a massive amount of guys.
Trevor Berbick.
I mean,
sure guys are kind of lost to history at this point.
Yeah.
That's who Tyson beat.
Remember mark was a champ.
It fell,
it fell down three times from one punch that was quite,
remember Wilma mills lane was a referee.
He was 20,
right?
Yes.
Sorry about that youngest heavyweight champion of all time.
Why I'm coughing.
I'm not even sick,
but it's almost like I feel like I have a,
you know,
I eat pistachios.
You,
he'd get one of them little,
not the,
not the shell,
but that little outside layer of the pistachio.
I almost feel like you're head.
A little piece of that in the back of my throat could be,
you never know.
Never know.
Can we just,
that Jenks of have another commentator across from me.
You know,
you're trying to make you cough project more.
you're trying to,
I don't think it's like a little battle,
Bro.
Thinking.
No,
no,
no.
We're,
we're good,
bro.
We're good,
Come on.
I want to know what the fuck is going to happen with Connor.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean,
you and everybody else because Hubby,
you and everybody else after this performance
Habibi set it up to a place where he's the most terrifying,
lightweight contender in the world.
And then you have Tony Ferguson,
who's a motherfucker.
He was the interim championship champion.
And then you have Connor who,
who knows what's going to happen with him.
And I think the UFC is going to give him a little while.
I'm,
can we give them some time,
you know,
hey,
let the holidays pass.
See what the fuck happens.
And they're going to have to make some moves,
but they want to do a Russia fight.
Yeah.
And if they want to do a Russia fight,
I know a guy,
I know,
I know the guy.
Little sell some fucking tickets and Russia baby.
Yeah.
Tony Ferguson as can be,
but never got off in Russia.
What could be said on Twitter about this?
Connors?
What kind of says,
yeah,
I'll let you go.
Skin to skin your pets and only wearing it once.
That's
truly,
truly get on your fucking knees and beg me otherwise I don't give a Bollix my
whiskey is out this year.
And that's ditty bread.
No,
but I think below that is the,
so he tweeted the bear thing and then it was I skin your pets and I wear them
once.
Oh yeah.
That was pretty funny.
That's comparatively witty.
Slaughter your pets and wear them as coats and only wore them once and I only
wear them once,
but there it'd be a lot of,
it's good trash talk.
I like it.
Have you ever seen the documentary called a Bobby Fischer against the world?
No follow chest.
There was a,
there's a document about Bobby Fischer called Bobby Fischer against wall and
whether or not you're in the chess,
you should really,
really watch it.
I'm into Bobby Fischer.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's called Bobby Fischer against the world and yeah,
he was.
And uh,
anyway,
they interview one of his,
his friends as long friends,
lifelong friends named Dr. Anthony Satie.
And their last conversation before Bobby cut him off,
he said,
Bobby,
if you don't play chess,
eventually they'll come a time where no one will ask you to play chess.
That's the situation is,
you know,
you can keep doing this and tweets,
but the reason you're famous and the reason people you have what you have in
front of you is because you fight.
And there comes a time when,
like I said,
the division with the sport in the division,
everybody,
it'll move past you now.
Economy have enough money.
He doesn't care about that.
But that,
that's always a risk.
You want who you know,
and you're an old school,
ain't no sugar.
Ray Robinson tried to be a dancer,
entertainer and a kind of old,
and they went,
yeah,
we want to see you fight.
And that's all you're gonna get paid for it.
Now.
He may not have enough money that he doesn't care about that.
Certainly possible,
but there's no sport.
There's no division that won't move past you eventually.
And that would be a shame.
And he thinks he has enough money.
Yeah,
but he's,
he's spending like Floyd Mayweather.
Yeah,
I mean he's going off.
If you go off like that after,
why are you going to run out of money?
Yeah.
I mean it might be 20 years from now,
but you know to see him till 20 years and your window to make monies this big in
professional sports.
Right?
You see I'm holding on my thing and make it.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's a,
I don't know if that's sustainable.
I don't know if he's got enough money to live the rest of his life,
but he certainly doesn't.
If he just spends like crazy,
I mean he might just go through a phase and then he might decide to cherry pick
specific fights to make tremendous amounts of money.
And then there was some talk about a pack.
Y'all fight in boxing.
Who knows what he's going to do.
But his only sustainable avenues.
MMA.
Yeah.
Meaning once again in boxing,
let's say he fights many pack Jaan.
Let's say he loses for argument's sake,
let's say he loses that fight.
People even get tired of spending 70 bucks on a pay per view to watch him take
on a great guy.
And fall shot and we'll fight Tony Ferguson and a unification fight and Kaos
Tony Ferguson then,
then fight Manny Pacquiao all day long.
Exactly.
It's,
it's MMA that sustains him.
You don't get mad at me,
Tony.
It's just that for instance,
the flexibility for argument's sake,
I'm taking the devil's advocate position.
Tony.
Tony got mad at me wearing the hat.
He's like,
what are you changing your ted planet gear,
Bro?
What were you were,
um,
I don't know how to say it.
Kapooka oh,
that for,
for the,
I'll come on to gift.
It's a gift to wear that and listen just because he's got a problem.
I love Tony,
but I also love Khabib,
Khabib as a bad motherfucker to,
to not to deny that it's ridiculous that ms to it.
So.
All right,
I've got to ask.
Commentator comes here.
All right.
What's,
what's the,
the madness to fight has ever been at you?
For what man?
I don't know.
Cause we all have these stories.
Not many of them.
Usually I get along with everybody,
but if I get along with just about everybody too and if there was ever a rampage
was we're mad at once.
I remember the hand as was,
I was saying that he'd need to throw more leg kicks or something like that,
but it's just cause I want them to be successful and when he does he's,
I just think that guys get a little too knock out heavy sometimes and I like to
see people be more technical and mix it up in addiction man and you're never
going to get away from the power that rampage had and has.
He's always going to have that power.
But my thought was like what I would like to see as a person who is a fan,
I'd like to see him mix it up more and become more technical.
He's always going to have that ridiculous chin.
He's always going to have that unbelievable power.
Those,
those things are not going away.
He's the first guy ever grappled with rampage,
rampage Jackson,
first guy ever grappled with really it had a legit studio.
I grappled with him once.
We were doing something for some television show,
some inside the that's right,
that inside the UFC thing that I used to do like way back in the day.
That was like a,
when spike first had the UFC we did some stuff and he was getting ready to fight
chuck and we did some stuff together.
He like a lot of people didn't know who he was.
He came around,
we drove around La in his a monster truck.
He had some crazy monster truck.
It was like Jack Three feet of the year.
If you wanted to provide you to know that it was no,
not that point.
What that point.
Of course we ran into one of the [inaudible] before that I was with rampage.
We ran into one of the Wu Tang clan,
you know,
weird section of La on Hollywood boulevard.
He's a loop test was coming out of a check cashing place.
I forget which guy it was.
We were having a good fucking time though.
That was before anybody knew who rampage was.
I misunderstood him cause he was going by the slug once again,
like 99,
2000.
I had finished it,
Ucla where I first got my taste,
Jujitsu was at Ucla and then I got,
I graduated and I went to teen punishment and I get on the mat and Fabiana you
was the coach there at the time finding out what the best arm bars in the day.
Monday?
Yeah,
it was fine.
Especially Farside.
And so we,
um,
I got on the mat and I shake hands with this dude and I said,
hey,
my name's Jimmy.
And he goes,
I'm rampage.
And I thought I misunderstood him.
I was like,
uh,
he can't sit,
you know,
I was like as a Randall or something and I just misunderstood him.
And all I knew was I knew armbarring foot locker at the time and he was so big.
I was like,
I'm just gonna put login.
And I went all straight,
full lux on them.
And again,
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna.
And then I got an arm bar on him and he lifted me up to the ceiling with one
arm,
just eroded.
My ass just went,
boom,
drop it right on me.
And Fabiano comes running over mad like,
oh,
you're not supposed to do that.
And just start screaming at him and he walks off ramp.
He turns to me,
he goes,
that'd be cool,
right?
That was like,
yeah,
we're fine,
man.
I'm a wrestler.
That's,
you know,
no big deal.
I've been slammed before and that was it.
That time it meant Quinten man back then.
The case like his second fight is for,
I was there right after his first fight or before it's first side,
like literally it was just getting started,
like living in his car stuff and now he's come very,
very far.
He's one of those guys.
I'm really glad [inaudible] half Harvey and he's been like one of his first.
That was his,
I believe that was his first.
His first fight it king of the cage.
California was Marvin.
He,
I think he fought once in Tennessee or something.
But yes,
of all,
Marvin East me lost my decision.
Whew,
man.
And then you just started beating guys up.
Starting Long History of the sport has now when you think about it,
it's interesting because it's all just sort of accumulated like the different
styles and the different abilities.
Do you remember how tough,
especially in California in the early two thousands the local scene was a
motherfucker?
Yeah,
cause the EOC,
like MMA was big.
It was not big,
but it was pop.
It was cool.
It was like it was popular,
it was fun and there weren't many big shows.
So guys had to fight on the local level for a while to get enough fights to get
there.
And also,
once again,
the contracts weren't that restrictive.
So in between UFC fights,
because they didn't have that many guys could go down to king of the cage and
make some money.
So you'd see some really talented guys.
The cage,
the cage was always weird challenge Indian Boba casino man.
That's where I fought at first.
I felt like for my fights up there,
there was a bunch of casinos that would have it and it all had to be native
American reservations have their own rules.
Yeah.
It was illegal weighing in on a bathroom scale,
like literally like on the bathroom scale in the lobby of the hotel and Ted
would look down and go,
yeah,
you're good.
You know,
whatever.
The doctors test was like,
can you find your nose?
Can you stand on one foot?
Can you stand me up for it?
Okay,
get in there.
It was literally,
that was it.
It's crazy.
It's wild west man.
Do you remember when the king of the cage,
it got rainy and they decided to let everybody fled in one bra.
Wet and wild.
That was crazy.
Then words fall on that card against Jeremy One.
Did he really?
I believe so from a team.
Angie,
do you mix generation?
Remember him?
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
It was a solid team.
Chris Brandon's camp man back then.
Solid dudes,
man.
Yeah.
There was a two Jeremy Williams,
right?
It was the one on top who wound up getting locked up in the news.
Jeremy,
the original one who took his own life.
Yeah,
it online.
Very sad story.
He was a really interesting,
super talented too.
I find a grappling match against Jerry at no limits.
Remember?
No one is,
yeah,
we're calling.
I'm going to be anyway,
so I got a call from the guy who ran no limits and he called me and said,
hey,
I have a grappling tournament come up.
Would you like to fight?
Because I was done,
you know,
I was doing grappling terms of the time.
I said,
yeah,
sure,
no problem man.
And because,
yeah,
I'm a super fighting.
It's Jeremy Williams.
I don't want,
cause I had seen Jeremy Williams,
you know,
he was locally in California.
He was known and we got in this ring or whatever and we fought.
And um,
I caught him and told,
and I,
and he tapped in and
I went back into the locker room and he's bawling,
like bawling,
bawling,
but like devastated.
And I remember thinking at the time,
that's like,
it wasn't in grappling when and got caught me and it happens.
And like his whole team was around him like,
like,
like a funeral or something.
And I,
and I went up to,
and I was like,
man,
I've always been a huge fan,
which is true.
I mean,
I,
I'm a local,
especially at that time.
He was like,
here he was,
he was a level above most guys.
And I told him,
and I'm a huge fan and it's just not a hundred fuck you.
And he said,
thank you.
And he hugged me.
But I remember thinking at the time,
something's going on.
Like he just seemed so emotional,
so devastating and what was going on his life at time.
And,
and uh,
when I went to Japan for five quest,
I read the deed.
He hadn't taken his own life.
And I that,
that was tough,
man.
I was tough.
Woof.
Oh yeah.
It's not all sunshine and rainbows and him on man.
Well,
it certainly isn't.
it isn't in any combat sport.
Right.
It's tough.
And it's hard to tell what is,
what's happening.
Is it what leads you to it in the first place as you have this burning desire to
get back at people and your emotions are in turmoil and obviously everybody's
different.
Yeah,
man,
it's one of the things about Rory that's so unique,
like people have this idea of him and then,
uh,
he did my podcast and one of the things that people said like,
oh,
he's fucking normal.
Like he's like a regular guy.
He just,
when he's fighting he's really serious.
Yeah.
But when you talk,
everybody thought he was like this complete like total silence psycho.
But then he's doing the podcast,
he's joking around,
he's self deprecating.
He's super honest about like what happened to when he trains too much.
He breaks down,
he can't do it anymore.
And I always,
he's like scheduled his training differently.
We just fucking,
he's not like,
I'm some superman.
I can't be stopped.
I'm never tired.
I'll fucking keep pushing.
There was none of that.
Yes.
People always ask me about jail.
Like,
what's that dude?
He's a,
he's a totally normal guy.
He's fun.
He's funny.
He's engaging self deprecating too.
Yeah.
You know,
I talked to him after the Tito fight.
I was like,
yeah,
he comes up to us and we're,
you know,
we were calling a fight after you'd already fought to then we're calling this
fight and I mean,
how are you doing?
He goes,
well,
I'm a competency shot.
Uh,
beyond that,
I'm,
I'm great.
I'm done crying.
I was in the bathroom just bawling and now I'm going to,
he's a funny dude.
He's a really a funny guy.
When he choked out Shogun,
he said something to the effect of he goes,
uh,
he goes,
if you think I'm going to sit here and listen to a middle aged comedians,
tell me what to do.
I just choked out a world champion.
Something along those lines.
You just wait for it.
You just,
whatever.
Like when I interview him and,
and by the way,
for,
for people in some way,
I don't know how it is for you.
Interviews are,
if not the hardest part of our job,
the,
the x factors in interviews because everybody asks me,
and this is kind of like a behind the scenes thing,
we don't know whether or not we do an interview is a production call 100%.
We don't decide.
I don't decide personally whether or not somebody gets an interview.
When I was doing military,
we have commercials so they have a commercial inventory.
We've got to get to him if fights and quickly we get interviews.
If they don't,
we don't,
it doesn't matter who the fighter is and what they're doing,
but it's not my call.
Um,
they're geeked up on adrenaline.
They're like all over the place.
The producers in my ear going,
you know,
you have one or two questions.
How ever many I have,
how many do I have time for?
They can go off crazy.
Like you just don't know.
It's the most x factor part of our job because it's off the format.
You're up there holding the mic and they could say whatever that you have no
idea what they're saying,
what they're doing,
trying to keep them in one place.
People don't realize that people go,
oh,
you guys were always touching the fighter.
If they start moving,
all the cameras move guys,
and it ruins the shot.
We're trying to keep them in one place.
When I put my hand on a guy,
what I'm trying to do or Gal,
whatever,
I'm trying to keep them in one place.
So the two cameras get a shot of them,
kind of sent it to me.
If it works,
it really works.
But when they have adrenaline,
they'll start spinning around or they're trying to address the crowd and they
start turning around.
You're trying to keep them in one spot.
I had one guy,
one the weirdest tweets I've ever gotten was sometimes you'll catch me on camera
pointing at the ground and what I'm saying is stand right here,
come to me and Stan.
Right?
So that's where the camera shot is,
you know,
I'm not right.
And so at every now and then you'll catch me doing that.
And what I'm doing is you stand right here because my director,
you saw I was getting mad at me cause I would go to the fighter and would like
ruin the shot.
He wants them to come to them so it's center this Weirdo tweet me cause it's so
racist.
The way you point to your shoes.
I swear to God he said like you point your shoes when it's a black fighter and
the last card hadn't had any black troll.
It was [inaudible] I was crying laughing kid from fortunate of Dude it was hell.
But like how demeaning and you point to your shoes when you're like what am I
do?
Like explain to you how a two shot works.
It is hilarious where people get mad at me cause why didn't that fight or get an
interview and I'm like it,
it's literally a timing thing.
Yeah,
you can't do with me.
You can't breed that stall.
You can't at all.
I'll read it and then that's about it.
I don't engage with anybody.
I don't know if you got a better shit to do,
but you can't get upset at people that don't understand the format.
It's crazy.
You're upset.
You're like legitimately upset.
That's not,
I was doing that.
The fucking Jews.
Yeah,
they really get,
they really,
really lose it.
Oh Shit.
It's a small percentage.
You know,
there's a million people watching and you get one shitty tweet.
You've really got to think about the number.
Yeah.
Well the thing to me too is like when I,
when I left Beltone when it came out,
whatever it was,
the 26th the response like kind of blew me away.
I mean,
I was hearing from people that I didn't even know they knew who I was.
Just,
you know,
everybody was just,
it was a huge deal.
I couldn't believe it,
you know,
I didn't expect all the support I got and I really appreciate anybody listening.
I really,
really appreciate it.
And when something like that happens,
it's the first time I heard from you.
It was when I left bell for the first time when Bjorn was,
you know,
being born and I left and you wrote me and when man keep your head up,
it's going to be great.
And I was like,
Eh,
no,
you knew who I was.
You don't know.
You're kind of cut off.
You have no idea.
But the support you get when you really need,
it's really amazing and may fast.
Well,
if you're a fan of the sport and you enjoy watching it,
you want a commentator who appreciates it and knows what he's talking about and
is entertaining.
Like you take good paths.
You know,
when you describe things,
I like to thank you,
criticized referees.
If they make shitty calls,
you do the right thing.
You know,
you speak up for the people that are watching.
That's,
you know,
that's something that's so hard.
You have to do it.
Yeah,
let's do it.
Even if you love the referee,
even if you love the referee.
But a lot of things are like one time and uh,
I love this in big John,
if you're listening,
I would love to hear an explanation of this,
cause this is one of the funniest moments I've ever had commentating was it was
Marlon Sandro versus Frodo hospital.
I have at one 45 and Beltre and I forget who got a cup shot,
but somebody's got to cup shot,
boom,
kicked,
kicked to the nuts and big John walks up to him and goes,
[inaudible] was Mike so I could hear it.
He goes,
that wasn't a bad shot.
I'm only giving you two minutes.
Oh.
And I went,
I'm on air going,
I don't think he can do that.
It's either five minutes or he didn't get hit.
He asks you fighting.
There's no,
but he went up to him that wasn't bad and we'll give you two minutes.
And I went.
So I'm on like I have to explain that to an audience and go,
as far as I know he can't do that.
It's either five or it's nothing.
Would when a referee does something like that you,
you,
I'm trying to explain to the audience what he might be thinking like,
ah,
that didn't look bad to me,
but here's what he's thinking.
And then fighters and then a lot of people think you're defending the referee.
No,
I'm trying to think about what could possibly make him do that.
You have to ride that line and go,
this is what he's thinking.
I disagree about that,
but what I bring in arbitrary,
the good thing about the UFC is you bring in mark Ratner has progressed or goes
over the the actual law or the rules rather and how it's set up.
The one of the things,
it's interesting,
we did a show in Detroit and I believe it was in Detroit and Michigan,
they make use of the replay,
but when they use the replay,
the fight is over.
Wow.
They make use of the instant replay.
But if they do have to go to the instant replay,
the fight is over.
And for what?
For no contest.
Is it for anything only you get to know con,
but when would that even be useful?
If I was some sort of an injury or if someone claims that a shot was in an
illegal area to declare a no contest.
Yeah,
that's the only way it could really work.
Well the owner,
the only way they can go to once they go to a replay,
so if the referee makes us call and then they request some sort of going to the
instant replay,
the fight is over.
There's no fighting after the instant replays played.
You don't,
it's,
it's weird.
It's so funny when,
when when people ask me about,
you know why there's so many controversies in m and a in MMA,
I'm sorry,
combat sports is the only major sport.
Boxing and MMA where the rules are kind of subjective.
The scoring kind of subjective.
When a fight is over,
it's kind of subjective.
There's just so much room for interpretation in every facet of our sport.
You know,
when a fight,
when a referee stops,
if I had,
it's his judgment as to whether or not intelligently defending yourself as is
the case.
You know,
the scoring 10,
eight,
10,
nine,
that's completely,
they make criteria,
but it's in the end.
Effective striking and effective grappling is subjective,
you know,
and so,
and also the fouls,
when I was in Israel,
a guy took a Jeremiah Lapiano,
took a groin shot and then shot the back of head and referee took 0.2 different
infractions.
Lot of referees won't do that.
You have to have at least two of the same infraction.
The Ref took a point away.
He's allowed to do that.
Um,
so,
so much the sport is subjective.
That's why there are so many arguments about this sport is,
you know,
so many subjective elements in it.
And that's why it's so important to have really good referees.
It's hard to find them.
They don't get any praise and they only get,
they get hate when they mess up.
Yeah.
Don't get praise and they do the job well.
It's uh,
it,
I mean,
what you said is perfect.
I think the,
the most locked solid is the rules.
That's the most locked,
solid scorings very subjective.
And we,
we're talking about the Khabib fight the,
even though there were using the old system,
I mean the scorecards were crazy.
I mean it could be was way ahead of him.
I don't see if you can find it Jamie,
but um,
it could be was way,
way out in front.
That's something that I do not miss doing is scoring.
Scoring.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think it's smart.
I did not know they used to make you do that over at bell two.
I don't miss that at all.
I mean I'll mentally kind of score or fight as I'm going along,
but,
but the thing,
and what's so funny is people's reactions to it.
Not that I mind doing it,
it's that people,
you know,
Steve Farr hood and like I said,
I just finished talking to news,
does it for a strike force.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
it's,
you can't make a scorecard that,
that everyone agrees with that we'll do.
People agree with that.
It seems we're on a 10 point must system.
You know,
10 or less.
And we have 30 25 30 25 and 30 24 and four a three round fight.
So clearly this is,
these are extraordinary scores.
So this is a 30 24 is ten eight and every round ten eight and every round when
she said the other two were ten eight and last two rounds.
Yeah,
that would be my guess.
I think it's right though.
I think 30 24 is right.
100% it was a mauling what I used to look for before the rule change was a
complete dominance.
It's gotta be one sided and there has to be moments where I go,
this should be stopped.
There has,
and there were a couple of moments in every round with in the cubby fight,
we tend,
when I sought attitudes rounds,
Dominick Cruz and I after this,
after the fourth round or the second round,
rather,
we said,
do you think that it,
you know,
this is a good argument for stoppage right here.
The corner could be really within their best judgment to say,
hey,
this is enough.
The people I was with turns me and they said,
what do you tell your guy at this point?
I say,
show me something.
If you don't show me something first minute of this fight tiles going in,
you got,
you know,
you've got gotta tell your guy,
look,
you're getting handled here.
We've got to start thinking about your health and your future.
If I don't see something in the first minute,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm calling this month.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if Ed's and landed a flying knee three minutes into the third
round?
I mean,
if it did turn that fight around,
I mean it would have been one of the greatest comeback.
What she was capable of doing.
He's the kind of guy who could,
who could maybe throw that kind of thing.
It just didn't seem like it was going to work on,
could be.
He just,
he was mauling him to an extent where he was draining his energy to the point
where Edson,
we'd get up and he was trying to be mobile,
but you could see the wobble in his step.
He just wasn't steady.
He wasn't able to uncork and he was just under a salt.
Also recently under assault,
there's a difference between a guy who can knock you out and a guy who's
naturally heavy handed everything you throw his heart Barbosa is a knockout guy,
but it's essentially his accuracy.
He's very,
very precise with what he throws.
Um,
he's not heavy handed enough to like necessarily club you with a shot and knock
you out.
He's not,
you know,
it's somewhere his kicks and they know what kind of guy you have in a sense,
once again put you,
she'll pitbull and belt or that dude's just heavy handed.
He can hit you with anything.
It's gonna hurt you.
So if you're a guy,
that kind of guy,
and maybe he wins it last 30 seconds the last round.
But if you're a kicking guy who needs accuracy and timing and a guy is coming
forward like Kobi was coming forward,
what are your,
you don't have a ton of options,
you know what I mean?
Know what kind of guy you have.
No.
Yeah,
you are in a lot of ways.
Well,
it was in a lot of ways it was,
it was a giant test for Khabib cause we wanted to see what he looked like
against one of the most elite strikers in the division.
But a lot of time often there will also was a big test for Barboza.
It's like,
cause you're going to have to use your hands here a lot and that's never been as
strong skin.
Strong suit has been as kicking though.
He knew how to negate that and move for the whole time.
Yeah.
And it fit or cro cop fade or step forward with the entire time knowing that cro
cop needs an outside game for the tour.
Yeah,
just set the footwork traps and it's so difficult to move back constantly.
It's so much more exhausting to constantly moving back.
And you know Barboza was just getting chased cotton.
Imagine if that fight was in,
you know we have two cages.
We have the smaller cage to use for the ultimate fighter and then the bigger
cage,
the use for,
I kind of liked the idea of the smaller cage for everything.
I kind of think that you can move around a certain amount,
that big ass cage,
like let's get some more seats in this bitch.
Put the little cage in here and I mean the problem is I found in some tiny
cages,
oh stuff there's been some real little one says man,
I used to have some of those local shows.
Real little ones like smaller than this room.
Whenever I train.
It was always never more than like two steps backward.
So you hit the cage,
you just,
you start hitting the fence,
you can get cornered.
So whenever we train,
it was two steps left to still try to la.
That second day really limits a lot of,
you're striking a hundred percent yeah.
It says,
have you ever thought about like a alternative venues?
Like what would be a good alternative venue for maybe we talked about on the
podcast with the fight companions all the time where I think like a football
field or a basketball court,
I think like something will you fight in the center and you have plenty of room.
We never go outside of it.
And he Duke it out there like lion heart and shit like that.
Like an underground basement.
No Pool.
Remember they find a pool motherfuckers,
well if you went to uh,
we,
we show science in the same arenas where they have basketball games,
right?
Yeah.
We've got all these dudes running around on this area.
But then when the fight takes place,
you know,
also we've got to put up a cage.
How about you just like keep that same size area,
the guy standing in the center and you know,
there's warning track where people are waiting on the outside edge.
Just tell him to go back in.
But there's never a time we can press someone up against the cage,
tried to get a take down.
It just doesn't exist.
There's no cage like,
so you don't have that extra thing that's in there.
That's a factor because that is,
the cage is a factor of 100% a hundred percent a factor in your backward
movement.
It's a factor in your ability to get back up.
It's also a factor in some people's ability to hold you in place and to defend
against submissions.
Right.
The cage.
You can't roll into certain things.
What if that wasn't there?
That would change a lot of what a wrestler can do inside the Octagon for sure.
It would either be awesome or absolutely terrible.
There's not a lot of middle ground.
Yeah.
I think,
do you remember when frank shamrock tried to do something like that?
He had a thing called shoot box.
Do you remember that?
Yeah,
I do.
He had let her saw it was like a shallow bowl and you would fight in the middle
of Yama.
Did that thing.
Yeah,
so did is Norris's world combat and leave and they have kickboxing and that kind
of a thing.
If they had like a little,
and Dan was fun.
Yup,
he did.
I think Wonderboy might've as well.
It's a piece.
Yeah.
I think he did crazy.
Raymond Daniels is fucking monster.
Who going to be slow?
John White,
Bro.
Dude.
Jefferson,
the old men in the sport of Oscar.
41 still smashing people,
dude.
Unbelievable.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Belt or kickboxing.
That's one thing that I really enjoyed that they did that they really focused on
worldclass kickboxing,
you know,
I mean guys like Joe Schilling,
uh,
Raymond Daniels,
they have like some of the best people from the kickboxing world that came over
were competing for them and they're making a big deal out of it and just put it
on exciting coker baby.
He really loves kickboxing.
No,
he does.
Yeah.
Well it didn't used to work for K one.
Yep.
It was this thing,
man.
Yeah.
That's where he started back in the day.
I think I got tickets for him from the Bellagio like way back in the day when
Peter Earth's fought.
Stefan Leco.
Oh Shit.
Old School.
Dutch lumberjack man.
Yeah,
man.
Brutal.
Yeah,
it awesome.
I'm a big
fan of kickboxing.
I like the fact that Bella toward decided to engage with both of those things.
Um,
Kevin Ross,
a gas Tom Bolanos,
but I just wish they would have like a completely separate thing.
Like make it a bit like,
and they call it bell tour too,
and people get confused and bill tour.
That's kickbox like Bella tour kickboxing.
Yeah.
Well it did.
Is it,
obviously they piggyback off the MMA shows.
It's already exists so we,
we shoot them together.
Right.
So they just changed the ring to a case to take.
They have it,
it lowers from the ceiling.
It's actually really cool if you've ever seen him before.
Yeah.
So what happens is they start out,
well when they started with the writing of the ring set up and all they have to
do is change the,
the mat and they cheated,
they take out the ropes and then the ring,
I mean the cage comes from the ceiling.
They have it suspended up there with the lights and it comes down and they play
2001 and they latch it in and then MMA stars do.
Man,
it's pretty cool.
Some people have recorded,
I hope you find it on well,
you know what's interesting,
Bella tour,
whether intention intentionally or not,
they nailed the correct shape for a platform in which are ranks.
It's on.
Yeah,
because there Bernard Hopkins fight when he fought Joe Smith Jr and he got
knocked out and he went flying through the ropes and fell and hit his head.
I was like,
oh,
how was this not protect?
How do they not have that figure it out?
Well,
the way to have figured it out would be to have more space on the outside of the
ring,
but the idea that you could just fall right through the ring and there's nothing
there to catch you.
All you would need is an extra four or five feet.
That's what we have.
Perfect.
It's perfect you guys.
They have figured it out.
They stopped doing that any more broadly.
I know.
I'll get you doing eventually they fucked up.
Who's going to take your spot?
I have no idea.
I really have no idea.
I've heard of it.
I mean,
I have a couple theories,
but I don't know.
No idea.
Now when it goes over to the paramount network,
yes.
When does that happen now?
Is it to the 18 look at this.
They lower from the ceiling
and they use a round one.
Yeah.
We use around Kj so it sits right in.
I like round two.
No need to have sharp edges,
but the octagon,
it's like it is what it is.
It's a thing now it's a thing.
Yeah.
Rounds.
Pretty dope though.
Not Bad man.
Works pretty well.
Um,
I'm sorry,
what were you saying?
Who might,
who might replace me?
I don't know.
Yeah,
no,
I have no idea.
What have they ever taught about changing their name?
No other they did years ago.
Well,
years ago.
What were the options?
I don't know.
I think,
I think at one point they were thinking about using the network name,
so it'd be like spike MMA,
but I don't know how far that went or,
and how many options they had.
I don't know why not like Hbo Boxing Box.
Kind of like that spike him in me.
I think that's the way to go.
Yeah.
The UFE well now it's not gonna work.
Well,
paramount network and MMA,
which doesn't roll off the tongue.
Exactly.
Spike MMA sounds good.
Yeah.
Paramount.
And they were considering that.
Well,
yeah,
the 18th I think they change over and then their first first belt are shown
there was on the 20th two days after.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Spike TV.
MMA.
Yeah.
Why paramount network paramount.
Come on.
You had spike for a long time.
But at the HBO boxing champion though,
Right.
You know when they up a belt.
That's true.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
That actually is a very good point.
Like there should be some sort of a,
a sanctioning body.
Yeah.
I mean they tried that member whammo memorable Amador won the championship was
there was affliction and they tried to kind of make a belt,
but it was called both the Ama,
the gene realize how that would sound.
What am I am on?
So what happened was they tried to make a belt that was independent of any
particular promotion.
Yeah.
Meaning the women belt would move when that fight or went somewhere else and
yeah,
just the way him and may work.
That was never going to fly.
Just let people like,
well why not?
I mean it does that and boxing.
Why not?
And there's no good answer.
Well,
the answer is that the brands are much more protective.
What is this?
It's Donald Trump Wellville that is high layer.
He was there.
I was there now Sylvia versus fate or,
yeah,
that was the first when my belt,
right?
Yup.
Dude,
that's a whole Lynch Shinier.
You wanted beaten somebody.
I forget who's got that.
Well,
we belt know who's got that bitch.
Somebody has to,
you have to find out now like maybe we need to bring me on my back.
So whatever.
It became a of Emilia Akos Wema belt.
Anyway.
Yes.
I do not know this.
Things that you wonder like a fighters' union,
like maybe he's that kind of work,
you know,
a sanctioning body outside of the UFC.
It seems like the momentum is so strong in the fact of the UFC being the
dominant organization.
It's like cue tips,
you know,
it's like that name.
Like cotton swab.
Yeah.
Oh,
but there's a cute tips like the NFL.
Can I have a facial tissue?
Uh,
what,
what Kleenex.
Come on bitch.
Well then,
all right,
so let me,
one of my pet peeves that I,
I'll explain right now that falls in line,
right with that I hate with a passion.
I hate explaining to people what I do for living.
Really.
I fucking hate it when I was a belter.
Why?
Oh,
because you worked for bell tour?
No,
because what happened was like I'm in a cab,
leaving it on the,
and they go and they go,
uh,
hey.
Uh,
so where are you coming?
When are you coming from?
Oh,
you know,
Miami.
What are you doing?
Work,
what kind of work do you do?
I'm a commentator for mixed martial arts fights and you'd just get a blank
stare.
They just have no idea what you were talking about.
And then you go,
you know where they put people in the cage and they fight and then they go,
oh,
you,
I see you worked with,
no,
it's,
I got explained that MMA is a sport and belt.
I've had this conversation 50 times.
It's just your average.
Once again,
if I say I need a cotton swab or I need to clean my ears with it.
What?
I need a cue tip.
Okay,
I got it.
Don't Trump's coming up with the XFL.
He's re bringing it,
bringing it rich.
The XFL.
Yup.
He used to have the XFL.
Yeah.
Now he's coming back with the XFL again.
They're going to call Donald Trump.
It was um,
Vince Mcmahon.
I'm kidding.
Just joking around,
but it wasn't,
didn't John Donald Trump have something to do with the Xfl?
He did.
Right,
but now Vince Mcmahon's,
Kennewick man Xfo XFL return dream gets closer as WWE head Vince Mcmahon files
to sell shares.
You ever had any dealings with Vince?
Vince Mcmahon?
No.
I'm a fan of that guy.
He's character funding.
Unbelievable.
Jack.
That's fuck.
At 72 it's on the deal.
He's on all of them.
Steroids,
70 years old,
just fucking jacked.
One of the camera guys and bill towards is a guy named Bubba dean who worked for
name,
great name.
He worked for Vince for like 20 years.
He was Vince's guy.
This guy's stories.
You got to have come on,
son.
Got All his teeth knocked out by stone cold.
Steve Austin while doing a shoot.
Vince did know the camera guy.
Oh,
but he has these crazy stories of doing stuff.
When he got his teeth knocked down,
all that stuff and all these crazy Vince stories.
It's nuts.
Vince.
When Vince blew his quad out,
he like jumped into the ring and slammed his muscle on the edge of the a ring
accidentally and just literally separated his fucking quad muscle from the bone
and just sat there on his ass and kept going.
Unbelievable.
I mean,
just that alone man,
selling it like that.
I mean,
he couldn't even walk,
dude,
and he's selling the whole thing.
We talked to people behind the scenes about WDN.
What goes into it?
It's really incredible.
I've got jack you,
Jesus Christ chase us.
He saw jack.
That's the most jack seven year old of all time.
Who is that fake Mark Coleman behind him.
That's it,
dude.
Get some.
The juice goes straight to Mexico.
That dude,
he's got,
it wears a prosthetic phase and everything crosses that age at that age.
It's like anti aging.
It's legal.
Anti aging technology.
Oh,
let's be honest.
He's on more than that.
Oh yes.
I'm quite a bit,
that's not normal stuff.
He's going deep.
Fuck it.
You know like Stallone,
you know if you're going to do it,
go and at 70 it's like,
what do you know?
Why not?
I was telling her he's stolen my canary in a coal mine.
That's killing dot.
Yeah.
Watching,
watching,
see you.
[inaudible] to Altify,
how much to take and how much to hang up,
bro.
How do you feel going to get road rage?
Well,
one of the things that led lights not bro about rising and you know is that they
want,
they don't give that.
When you say I don't give a fuck,
they don't give it.
I think horizon,
she had Gabby,
I can't believe she's 26 pounds overweight.
I think it was 27 or 26 27 please.
Japan P is cheese.
If I could beg of you anything,
don't let Gabby go see a beat up any more.
Grandmas.
It's literally,
they think it's funny.
They biggest shit time picks up grandma's.
You know what?
No,
I'm sure this is something I've talked to people about a lot.
The old school fans was for it now that prides gone,
you know,
pride forever and probably never done a little pride.
Pride had some matches that made you go,
what the fuck is going on here?
They love that shit.
Love for each was for the Japanese audience.
So they would have got weight classes,
were suggestions.
They didn't test anybody.
Uh,
they would throw any,
you know,
experience level men,
absolutely nothing.
And there was a member of the Euro Matsui of course.
Sure.
That guy,
they loved watching that guy get beat up.
He fought everybody,
they matched,
loved watching,
does your mess.
So He'd get his fucking face beaten and they loved him and was like,
I didn't like him.
They,
there's something in the car.
They love that shit.
And I'll tell people,
I'll go look.
You know,
pride had,
did have some great fights.
It also had some fights that were crazy,
ridiculous.
Unbelievable mismatches.
Yeah.
The weight classes that mean their,
their appreciation for a fighter struggle was every if not yeah,
if not more important in the fight or being victorious.
It's like the fighter being just being Valeant in the face of overwhelming odds
was almost more enjoyable to them.
I like Bushido more cause they just didn't pull that in bushy though.
And they featured the lighter guys and I don't remember and Bushido any,
any fights.
I was like,
oh my God,
this things,
I think you're right.
Now that I'm remembering who Shito a bit more.
It was great.
They were all great.
That was when Quadros and uh,
was it quadros and I'm quadrants or the commentators?
Well it was in a moral,
moral quadros or more.
Oh boss,
those are those,
you know why I too,
they only had one or two shots at it.
That one guy who was a,
uh,
he was like some sort of a radio,
a sports guy.
What the fuck is his name?
Mad Dog or something like that.
God dammit.
He only did it once.
There was one guy for pride.
Yeah.
One guy who was the play by play guy with boss route and once he's fun,
it's like kind of silly guy but a little out of his element.
Little out of his element didn't,
didn't necessarily um,
took,
we were talking about earlier like
it's very difficult to find someone who's a play by play guy who is also a
martial artist and also like really,
really invested in the sport.
Whereas a guy like you,
a color guy,
those guys,
there's,
it's,
there's more chance that you're going to have a technical understanding of the
sport and also be able to be entertaining about it.
Whereas they just have to be entertaining about it and read the script.
They don't necessarily,
it's so it's super hard to find a guy who's as knowledgeable as you,
but that is also a play by play guy.
I always say,
I always said Brian Stann should do it because Brian Stann play by play.
And he could do either or,
but it would be different because Brian,
Stan has in my opinion,
he has the voice and the personality and the delivery that like the strength in
his,
like the way he formed sentences in an in an entertaining but powerful way.
Like he could be a really good believable play by play guy who's also super
legit martial artists.
So He'd be like the only guy that's doing it that way.
Well the problem,
the problem with having uh,
uh,
a play by play guy who's two nodule,
they start doing both of them sitting there and that's probably when the guy is
like a freak fan or thinks they know a lot about sports.
They start
doing it,
they start doing color as they're doing blood work.
I think that is as long as it's,
as long as everybody is aware,
like no one,
not one person talks too much and everybody kind of lets everybody go get in,
you know,
and,
and you,
it's like one of the things that I like to do when we have a DC or when we have
Dominick Cruz or whoever sits next to me,
sometimes I like to ask them questions like I want to,
I want to go in,
I want to give them a position like,
do you,
what do you like to do here?
Like how do you approach this?
Like what's your thought process here?
Or like for DC,
DC's and Dominic was amazing too this weekend about breaking down clinch work
and what someone's doing wrong or why this is a stagnant position for them.
And what,
you know,
like I think if you had a guy who was a play by play guy,
just as long as he knows,
as long as everybody's cool with everybody,
like everybody's flow,
you know,
like that I think.
But that is one of the things that came in really well with me and Goldie
because we'd worked together for so long since we knew how to slide things in.
We knew we knew when to talk and when you know,
and sometimes we just talked over each other like some shit was happening and
you know,
but that's okay too.
Yeah.
You know,
I've gone through four for the last year,
year and a half.
I did a few different guys back in the de identify,
Hey,
what the fuck?
Cut that out of the show.
Yeah,
we can edit that.
Right.
Cool.
I worked with a few different guys back in the day,
but one of the guys that people forgot who was amazing was Bruce Beck.
Bruce Beck.
Yup.
Bach.
I worked with him in boxing.
That PBC.
He gave me really good advice for what you were talking about.
It's difficult post fight interviews,
you know,
he's just gave me advice and having things to say and planning things out and
you know how to,
how to,
you know,
how to word things.
He knew I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
Matt Mitrione when when they hired him to do belt or kickboxing,
we were in Turin,
Italy and Matt mature and I think he was a priest back actually at that time.
He hadn't filled out yet.
So Matt Mitchell and he's there by himself has never done color commentary
before and all the kickboxing fighters are showing up.
I've already done MMA.
I wasn't doing kickboxing at the time.
I take Matt and I go,
okay,
cool.
I'll walk you through this.
So I stayed and helped him interview all the kickboxing fighters and he's
sitting there,
he's like,
need some advice?
You'd never done this before?
And I said,
the only device that game was,
don't say anything.
My mom knows if my mom's watching boxing and somebody was punched in the face
and in turn I'm going to go to that guy just got punched in the face.
My mom would go,
yeah,
I know that I can.
I can see that.
My mom knows when someone's getting punched in the face.
My mom doesn't know how the foot works.
Set that right hand up.
That's your job is not.
That guy just got punched.
I'll look at them.
It is not,
it's not fucking radio.
They can see it.
Okay,
so your job as the expert is to the things that a layman or someone not
experiencing sport doesn't quite know like footwork and combinations and stuff
like that.
And I said stick to that.
I go,
just stick to filling in the gaps that your expertise will help fill in.
Don't say,
Oh,
you know,
you don't have to say everything in the world.
And when everybody talks,
everybody loses.
That's how you have to think about it.
He knows when to talk and I don't wanna talk.
We don't talk over each other.
Everybody loses it when we talk over each other the same time we both sound like
crap.
So just no one,
you know,
you'll get a feel for window layout and wanting to go in.
But my number one advice was don't say anything that someone on the street could
look at the TV and figured out it.
Buffalo wild wings can yell at the TV.
Why are you here?
We don't need an expert.
Anybody can say that.
What do you feel in it made him feel way better.
I said,
they look,
just fill in this stuff than your average person would know.
That's a very good game plan.
That's very wise.
Very versatile.
Yeah.
Use this power for good.
That's what I was talking to something.
Don't say what my mom did.
You get caught up in and there's a right hand.
You don't have to call every,
they can see that now.
The hard part is the grappling people are,
a lot of people totally lost.
We have to call a lot with to fill in a lot more of that because sometimes you
want to react to certain punches.
They hit landed too,
and you just gotta know when to,
when not to.
It's that develops man.
Get a feeling for that,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a weird thing that you're thinking of it.
At least I am when I'm doing it also is like,
it's a product like you're contributing to a product.
You're like,
you're adding to it with sound and with description and with the entertainment
value of the way you distribute your words.
You know,
good broadcaster knows they're not tuning in for us.
Yeah,
we can make it better.
We certainly can.
We certainly can't.
Well definitely we're there to get out of our own raw.
Exactly.
Fuck it up 100%.
We can also detract from broadcast and you gotta be careful then detracting is
the worst.
Yeah.
I mean I know,
I think probably both been guilty of that at some,
oh yeah.
In any moment is not free balling.
You know,
you're doing a live thing and you have,
I mean,
when,
when you're anticipating things happening and they're happening or something's
different than you thought it was going to happen and you're trying to put the
words to it correctly and in the moment of live on TV,
it doesn't always work out how to get myself up so bad.
Man,
when I make a mistake,
man,
I'm mad me to fucking until the next show.
Yeah.
But,
and then I'll look sometimes like nobody noticed it.
I'm the one that that's mad at myself.
But that's why you're really good.
Oh Man,
I get mad.
That's why you really think,
I mean anybody who is really good at anything,
you get that way because if fucking up on it just seems horrible,
you know?
It just really messes with your head.
Yeah.
Any,
I've just come to accept that weird feeling,
you know,
and use it and go,
all right,
whatever that shit feeling is where I flubbed that word or forgot that guy's
name or whatever it is and I am conflated the two people,
whatever it is,
get over it,
keep moving.
Just do your best.
And that feeling because of the fact that I can't just blow it off,
I can't just be like,
who gives a shit?
I don't have that in me.
That's why I try hard.
And that's why with every broadcast when I get through it and it's good,
I'm like,
okay,
we did.
You know I still get that.
I still get that juice,
man.
I still,
every time,
and it's funny,
I'm for disappearing after a show.
I'm known for that,
for like the show's done and everybody goes,
well my AA,
I don't drink.
So I'm,
I'm out of that loop completely.
But what about your heroin use?
Uh,
you know,
all that,
that's a home thing.
I'm not going to bring it on a plane.
Come on rookie anyway,
so,
so anyway,
um,
I'm known for disappearing after a show because a show just takes a lot out of
me,
like everybody else out at the bar doing whatever.
And I go to my room and I,
I just download it.
You don't fucking starving after shows or that.
And the problem is that a lot of times it's,
you know,
when I'm out in,
in,
in
Vacaville or something or I'm out in like moving Kansas and you're at a smokey
casino and there's one place to eat and have a fight,
just let out.
And you're like,
oh my God.
You know,
it's like a real decision I have to make.
A lot of times it's MIT too hungry to sleep or am I too tired to eat?
Which one of those am I asleep?
I almost always use sleep.
Almost always sleep.
But yeah,
I just disappear.
I just go to my Gotcha.
Cause it's hard.
It's just takes a lot of money.
I bring stuff with me anyway.
I always bring protein bars.
I bring canned oysters.
I bring different things that I could eat that I know are healthy.
I'll bring like a bunch of cans of canned oysters cause it's like they're soaked
in olive oil for healthy bang.
A few cans those out go to sleep and family time.
What's that?
What does your family oh go and [inaudible] mostly Italian.
A little bit of Irish.
All my friend is Greek.
My Mom's Greek restaurant,
German,
Irish olive oil is a big part of the olive oils.
The shit that is one of the best fucking things your body can take in olive oil
is fantastic.
And what a pain that Dick it is to make you think about all the stuff they had
to go through.
Like when you see an,
I had an olive tree in my yard and uh,
the olives fall down these nasty little fuck.
I was like,
this isn't an olive.
And they're like,
oh yeah,
there's a whole process this.
Yeah.
Like I thought it all of came from a tree like at all.
But like you could just pick any one of those green ones.
No,
I grew up in San Joaquin Valley.
They had the whole thing set up there,
man,
until I was nine years old.
Yeah.
A lot of all of stuff.
A buddy of mine makes olive oil in his yard.
He's got a shit ton of olive trees in his yard and uh,
he,
he set this whole thing up with the hopes of eventually making his own olive oil
from his,
from his own yard.
Kind of good luck,
dude.
You can much easier to find the story,
but be part of the Diet growing up.
Mom cooks a lot,
man.
That's phenomenal for you,
You know what's funny?
My,
my,
my mom had had cooked for the belt or crew before really come over to her house
and she cooked for the whole crew.
25 people.
God Damn my mom.
She's like a caterer.
She loves that Shit.
Wow.
Anyway,
so literally,
you know,
I had my,
my,
I left bell toward literally one of the people went,
your mom,
your mom was still cook for us,
right.
Anytime.
Like we want mom and the divorce.
And I was like,
okay,
cool.
Mom,
mom's okay with it.
Mom loves everything.
Belts are coming live with my mother.
So it was kinda funny.
She had them all over for dinner and I hope they were really,
really upset about my mom.
I hope Bella tour makes it and I say that with all Doosan 70 to 100% now that
we're both not hundred pallet tour.
Yeah.
Both of,
now I'll talk about this.
Yeah.
It's like,
I always heard this before,
like maybe they are in competition with UFC,
the corporate entity,
but my,
in my opinion it's not,
it was never that they were in competition with me.
My thoughts are that they're valuable,
that it's important and that the more competition you have,
the better.
And then I also felt like having a guy like you out there who's doing
commentary,
who's kicking ass makes me better.
I know that you're really good at it.
I will listen to you.
Very sharp.
I listen to people and I'm sure you're the same way that they're uncomfortable
or clunky doing commentary.
It,
it's,
it makes for an awkward experience from me watching it,
we listened to it a lot.
I mean,
I really listened with that ear because that's our job.
You know,
you really listen with that ear and,
and you know,
you're probably overly critical.
We are at least when you're listening to,
but to our peers and,
and uh,
yeah,
I did the same thing.
I'm like bad commentary can really high and just kind of,
if you get good at like a producer can hear things where you go,
I don't even hear that.
Sure.
Something's a little off and just bugs him.
Just clunky,
you know,
especially for someone who's called and seen as many fights as you have.
Your idea of what's clunky is like you're,
the data chunking that you're doing is very different.
It's very much more high level than the average person.
There's just not a lot of people doing it.
Which tenure?
Yurman yeah.
No one time when I was doing art,
no,
I was doing and one before that.
Who Was it?
And I did affliction to those are both before,
but was Jason Chambers the first bell of the first year.
He was the belt organ when it was on Espn Deportes this and it was just a web
series in English associate could just see it on the website in English.
It was Anik and Jason Jammers.
Holy Shit.
That's crazy.
Jason and I have lived re weirdly parallel lives.
Yeah,
you guys both had that show.
We travel,
we fought each other.
He was my last professional fight.
He was a guy built over before I was there.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it's really weird.
It's really strange.
Yeah,
he was.
You were on what show was he was on fire.
He was on human robot.
Yeah.
So funny story.
When I first got the call about five west,
they,
so to go back a little bit further,
I fought Jason in my last pro fight and,
and uh,
I remember Jimmy Walsh,
she was the promoter.
Well you just train me.
Yeah.
Used to be my personal trainer.
He's taught me about kettle bells.
That man crazy English crazy.
He's one of John jocks.
Black belts timey.
Yeah.
Great grappling.
Grappling some twice.
Um,
anyway,
so I was going to fight Jason at his promotion called Pangea,
and he told me all about the show he was going on.
He goes,
man,
if you beat this guy,
he's going to be bad.
It'd be great for you.
And I was like,
and he could describe the,
showed me,
you travel around and you do different martial arts.
I was like,
man,
that's what's up.
That's a great idea.
And then I'd be Jason with the reverse.
He'll hook and you know,
how dangerous those are.
And Jason Really held out and,
and it,
it tore up pretty good.
And Anyway,
a couple of days later I get a call,
uh,
from,
I forget who and they said,
and they said,
yeah,
this,
they're doing the show and the,
the,
you know,
give this producer in New York.
It was okay.
I called the producer and she described the show when she described the exact
same show.
And I went,
oh fuck,
I heard him.
And they're looking for a replacement.
And I felt,
I felt,
cause there's an unwritten rule in MMA that you can beat somebody up and do
whatever.
You don't take food out of somebody else's mouth.
You don't want to hurt somebody and they can't fight for a year.
It sucks.
You don't,
you know what I mean?
Like real fight.
But when it's over,
it's over.
You don't want to like injure somebody to where they can't make a living.
That was also back all day.
We deal hooks were like sort of shunned in Jujitsu a little bit.
MMA fight.
I know,
but I mean there was a statement there,
her Cylus yeah.
Um,
but that's what I use and,
and,
and I thought I injured him and they were looking for a placement.
I just like,
oh my God,
I took the guys deep impact Armageddon thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
100%.
And so then I found out that I realized they were on different shows.
And it was so funny because people have said since then that I was chosen
because it'd be Jason and they know that's their assumption,
which makes sense,
but they had no idea the producers of the show.
Once I got the GIG and we're talking to said,
yeah,
there's no show on history channel.
I went,
yeah,
I fought that guy and they looked at me and they went,
what the hell?
Yeah,
I find him like a month ago.
They literally,
I'm serious,
had no fucking clue and they had no idea.
It's just so weird.
They both came out exactly the same time.
They were a few months before me.
Been one of those shows since there hasn't been one before.
It's like,
it's like what kind of weird shenanigans were going on,
but I was the route.
I didn't produce the thing so I don't know where it came from.
I have no idea.
I'm not blaming you.
It wasn't me.
It wasn't,
I didn't go,
Hey,
I can take this idea,
but it's just weird to me that those shows become interesting and popular.
And then they stopped being,
it's like someone tries it out and they go,
this is it.
And the two companies are willing to invest it in two different channels are
showing it.
I remember this,
this is,
this is a way back when in one summary was the abyss deep space.
Nine and Leviathan were all these like underwater horror movies that came out
the same summer and then you haven't seen it.
It's just the,
I don't know why,
it's like we're seeing with the asteroid movies deep,
uh,
deep impact.
And I'm a good Armageddon.
Both of them came out exactly the same time.
So that was weird.
It was really strange.
Yes.
Fucking Hollywood's bizarre like that.
It is.
Find out like,
what did,
I almost don't want to know.
I don't know.
Want to know what kind of weird shenanigans were all three.
You fuck heads are coming up with underwater Paul.
What's going on?
Yeah,
I have no idea.
It's like they find out that someone's doing it so they get ahead on on.
They tried to release it first and there were two battle of the sexes movies,
Spa Will Ferrell was supposed to play Bobby Riggs and a battle of the sexes
tennis movie.
Then they found out I was doing the other ones.
Yeah,
and then they found out Steve Carell was doing one and they they it,
hello.
That match happened in like 19 in the 70s that was the middle Jean King,
Billie Jean King.
Wow.
Went to my high school,
strangely enough like,
yeah.
Anyway,
but,
but 40 years later they make a movie at and two studios want to do at the same
time wear and both with Comedians,
which is really weird.
Oh,
Bobby Riggs.
Was that that guy like Steve Carell's so God damn good.
He just knocked these out of the park.
He was great playing that fucking creepy dupont guy to do Johnny dupont.
Yeah.
I remember when Dave Schultz got killed.
What a huge deal that was too,
but it was just what,
he was so creepy playing him in the movie.
It's like you bought it,
you bought that,
he's nailed the guy wrestling with these guys to them and shit and then just
like letting them do it.
Weird,
weird,
weird.
Have you seen the documentary about it but shows all of the real footage and
everything?
I've seen,
I've seen some of the real footage,
but I don't think I saw the documentary.
There's one 30 30 to one and then there's one on Netflix and I've seen both of
them.
One is like more focused on Mark Schultz,
the other ones,
the other story and man it's,
once again,
it's fucking creepy really out there.
Yeah.
Wrestlers just had no outlet to make money back then and this billionaire says,
I'll put you up and make this amazing team and they jumped on it.
Isn't it kind of stunning that wrestling never had a real actual professional?
Not that there's anything wrong with pro wrestling,
but pro wrestling obviously is a show.
There's never been like you think about like how many people love wrestling,
how many wrestling fans there are,
how many people wrestle in high school and college like and how many people
would like to watch it in the Olympics.
It was always a big deal.
Like why didn't they ever figure out a way to make some sort of professional
venue out of it?
Remember they did have a real pro wrestling.
They tried that and and you,
you know,
it's funny,
I,
I used to teach IB teacher and what I did before I was five,
which teach,
uh,
the longest I ever taught was good.
I worked for Long Beach Unified School district.
I did a bunch of stuff for them.
So sometimes I would tell you sometimes I do this testing stuff.
The longest ever taught was seventh grade math.
If there is a hell that is where it is.
A seventh grade math Algebra.
I only,
I only taught that Wa my mom's a teacher and the girl,
the lady two rooms down from her got sick or had some kind of breakdown and mom
went,
can you please come in and teach for a year?
And I went,
okay,
cool.
Cause it made it easier on her.
I said,
all right fine.
So I ended up teaching degree and degree and certification yet and I had both of
those.
Um,
so you'd already planned on teaching or how did it as a possible side game?
Possible Psyche.
It was,
it was always what I was doing kind of while I was fighting.
Um,
but anyway,
uh,
I had a teacher tell me one time,
he said,
if there's a sign at the zoo that says please don't throw tangerines at the
elephants,
it may not make any sense to you.
All it means is one time somebody threw a tangerine and elephants,
something really bad happened.
And I thought about that a lot.
When,
when,
whenever you think about,
you know,
why is porous and caressing w there was a time when it was real and it was too
boring.
So they started scripting the endings to it and so it became pro wrestling,
you know,
it was,
there were catch wrestling matches and they lasted three hours and it was,
you know,
I was like,
the old Gracie fights to ages lasted too long,
you know,
guys couldn't catch each other.
And so they started scripting and he's real.
Pro Wrestling was an effort to make it work and if it had made money,
it's still me around,
you know,
so it sucks.
And I wish rustlers even had more of an outlet that MMA and wrestling itself has
gotten bigger in terms of,
I went to my old high school to watch a dual meet and back when I was there we
had like one varsity team,
like half a JV team.
They had varsity JV,
fresh off in a woman's team.
Wow.
A woman's team at full woman's team,
you know,
whatever.
I'm 14 weight classes right now and we couldn't get anywhere near that when I
was in school.
Like it just wasn't that popular.
Now MMA has made it huge like wrestling now.
I mean people really follow him.
You gotta be a real geek to follow college wrestling,
you know?
Well when you see the guy I met off smash Edson Barboza using essentially just
wrestling and vicious ground and pound.
You realize like,
okay,
like that is so fucking important to have.
It is the cornerstone or it's rather the foundation of MMA.
Yeah.
If a guy like,
and I think that fight really highlighted it crushed,
it really,
really showed like they dominant super dominant wrestler over the dominant
striker.
If the dominant wrestler can get ahold of the dominant striker,
the last that's trackers clothes.
Like that's one of the things that was most impressive about Mirko was it when
Mirko started fighting for pride,
his take down defense got really good really quick.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
He fought some fucking tough guys but figured out a way to keep the fight
standing a lot when I liked to him so much.
When you watch him is not only was the South Pole,
he was so good with the range of his foot work that he never,
he never lost his distance while throwing.
He was always really good at picking you apart from long range.
So you are shooting from outside,
you were shooting from way far back.
He could see it coming.
His footwork set up his take down defense so well and it was amazing.
Yeah,
he also was very powerful.
So his explosion was a big part of his fight style when he was a kickboxer.
So unlike maybe Peter Arts or a Nesto Houston who had more methodical,
technical style of striking cro,
cop would throw those one big shots all the time and that really works well in
MMA and he was able to use that explosion,
that fucking left high kick and the one of the body that he hit hit heath
herring with you.
Remember that shot collapsed him.
Well you see he hearings body just wrapped around cro cop's leg like whoa.
Just realize the amount of power in that fucking kick and herrings taking it
right on the rib cage.
The worst.
Now the,
the thing to me is when you watch what I tell people,
I said,
when you watch chuck Liddell's three fights against Randy,
the third one he gets Randy.
Randy is just shook by that power.
Just felt it before.
And that kind of,
you know,
bull in a China shop,
Greco sal to get inside.
It's not there.
He's just thinking about that power shot the whole time.
And that's what a power Stryker does against a wrestler.
He gives you that kind of barrier of to take me down.
You've got to get through here and here is fucking dangerous.
And I think cubby would,
he knew his long range is dangerous against [inaudible].
So if I keep moving forward,
like you putting pressure on him,
take away that spinning range,
he's not going to knock me out with his hands.
And that's why he
was pushing forward so incredibly hard as he didn't worry about that second
wall.
It really didn't concern him.
Yeah.
And Chuck would make you fight him because chuck was a very good wrestler
himself.
The thing that made chuck so unique is that chuck was a striker.
You know,
Hackleman train,
Kempo karate,
all that stuff in a lot of,
in a traditional sense,
but also have very good boxing skills and serious fucking power in his hands and
kicks.
But he also knew how to wrestle.
So good luck taking him down.
So now you're forced to stand up with this long powerful striker who has an iron
chin and just had this psychotic desire to move forward and land bombs.
He also had slow,
yeah,
I remember correctly.
Yeah.
He was a,
and that's where Hackman's place is still up there in San Luis Obispo.
He was something interesting because he was one of the very first wrestlers that
was a feared Stryker.
Yeah.
So he had the wrestling skills.
Great.
Take down defense.
Very good at getting back up off the ground when you hit him,
when he,
when he got down to the ground,
but also destroyer on his feet.
Yeah.
So that's the kind of guy that when you're going to need to test,
could beep to need a guy who can keep the fight standing,
who can test,
could be on the feet.
Some guy who's gonna be able to stuff.
Some of those take downs.
Those guys don't come around often.
Well now with him,
when you see what he did to Rda,
he ragdolled dos Anjos,
which is crazy.
I mean,
I do not know.
There's a timeline of dos Anjos dominance,
right?
And a strong seven.
Yeah,
yeah.
Sounds a strong 70 but this was a different time and still sound,
just training.
And I think dos Anjos made some giant leaps when he started doing strength and
conditioning with nick curse on,
he started doing it.
Just had way more output inside the cage.
And,
but the crazy thing was that dos Anjos is one of the best grapplers in the
division.
And you see what he was able to do with Neil magni leg kicks.
Neil magnet gets into the ground.
Smushes them,
you know,
I mean his,
his fucking ground game is really legit.
So to see him get ragdolled by Khabib,
you'd like,
how's he doing that to RDA?
You know,
it's nuts.
I had 55 yeah.
Yeah.
He's something special.
So it's like who is left at 55 especially now that dos Anjos has moved on
successfully to one 70 who the fuck has left that's going to be able to keep the
fight standing?
You know,
that's the tough part.
I don't think there are many answers.
I really don't know either.
Man.
I think you've got to put to put together the first who fight pretty quickly.
Not Coming.
I mean that's interviews my Tux.
It's a big fight.
That's,
that's the fight.
That's the fight.
The question is,
is going to be for the title,
is it going to be Ferguson and Connor get stripped and Ferguson and could be
fight for the undisputed title because they'll just make Ferguson the undisputed
champion.
If Connor gets stripped,
which I don't think is a bad thing,
no click.
Connor is still fucking Conner of Conner comes back a year from now.
Huge.
He still college.
It doesn't matter.
He's still fighting probably for the title right away.
Everybody's going to want it.
Everybody's going to want the paper view money that comes with it.
Hop on board,
but Tony Versus Khabib is very
interesting.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
You've done,
he was the guy.
You have to get his respect now.
I don't have to give them a reason to backup.
Tony knows how to fight off his back.
Very good.
Yeah.
Very dangerous off his back.
Not just getting dangerous off his back and turns into submissions,
but very good defensively off his back.
You know,
he,
he's,
he's got really good composure.
Very good wrestlers.
Chokes are fucking nasty man.
He catches chokes from weird angles,
you know,
as good at sweeping you.
He's,
he's legit.
He's legit champion.
That's the fight.
Yup.
I mean that's the funny thing else is advancing me calling for it could be,
yeah.
It's just what do you do though?
Like what,
what do you do and how do you do it?
You do,
you strip Connor.
That's always the question.
Cause if Conner is like fuck it,
I want to fight.
Tony didn't do upland decides to,
if he decides to come back and fight Tony and then the winter fights could be
even Russia,
the world explodes.
That'd be huge.
That'd be the biggest thing is fantastic.
The winter fights Khabib in Russia for the undisputed title.
You have a copy in Russia?
No,
but could we just got to ride a bear out to the cage?
It's gangster man.
Put a cage or it's literally gay.
It's really,
it's,
it's a mobbed up place.
Does it?
I,
it's fun there.
Yeah,
it was,
how many times did you,
uh,
think for W for bell?
Two arm.
No,
when I was at them.
One they run out of,
that's right.
That's right.
Saint Petersburg.
And then I did,
did you enjoy?
Oh,
the man had a great time.
How's the food over there?
Food's good.
I don't like the way you said good.
Not The food's good defense,
but it's not,
it's not like you're not known for.
All right.
So I got to tell the story.
We're,
we're on,
we're on the ship in the Nivo river and it's owned by one of the guys who runs
and one and,
um,
yeah,
so we're on the ship and then even river and it's got a restaurant on it and
we're sitting there and Sean,
we like Mobe Roscoe broadcast partners,
very persnickety about his food.
He's super thinking about a lot of stuff.
And we're sitting there with our boss and everything and the guy who runs this
ship of this big heavy and Saint Petersburg as affiliate with them,
one serves us this Borscht,
which is like,
you know,
uh,
beat students to basically,
and he goes,
man,
we're really proud of our boards.
It's a big deal here.
And Oh,
we hope you enjoy it.
It's,
it's a point of honor for us.
And he walks away and we lock looks at the boat and goes,
I'm not eating this,
I don't like it.
And our boss goes,
you will fucking eat it right now.
Like a seven year old,
like you will eat it.
And he's like,
no,
I'm not.
He like folded his arms like I'm not eating.
No Way.
No.
I ate so fast.
White people,
white people.
I eat so fast that I already ate it.
I like bore.
So I just,
you just ate it.
And I set my thing and I'm a guy who was all proud of his borsch.
Turns around is heading back to us and my boss looks at me and goes points to
Sean's boot and I grabbed it and I drank an entire bowl of that shit and threw
it down before the guy came back and he saw me.
Oh,
thank you so much.
Sean was just refusing to,
to touch it.
Persnickety is a nice word.
Oppression.
Even getting,
I like how you use that.
That's a great selective amount,
but it's a nice way like nobody can get mad.
Yeah.
It wasn't like he was like,
yeah,
he calls timeline then persnickety Vicky.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
They're a complaining bitch.
No,
see that.
I didn't think you would,
would not.
No,
you're getting,
I understand.
No,
I bet.
Even like Ali didn't.
I was like,
I'm fucking,
give it to me.
I know there's been some talk about doing it UFC in Russia and I think a lot of
it is probably based on the idea that could be at 25 and o is most likely
somewhere along the line I'm going to fight for the title.
I mean if everything continues to go well,
as long as there's no injuries or something.
Yeah,
especially now that he can make the weight like you made the way pretty easy.
Yeah.
It didn't look bad.
Not at all.
That would be huge.
Fight.
Fucking have enough rush and talent that you know.
Oh yeah.
Oh it was just from Dagestan alone.
You can fill the whole roster.
Yeah.
Dagestan versus the world.
He really could.
You almost cut what?
A fighter in belt or Shabbat Somalia and up getting shot like five times in
Dagestan.
He lived,
he lived,
but he went after some gangster with a gun or something in a club.
And it's crazy,
man.
It's a tough world.
Were so soft over here.
Sean,
we locked,
need to go camping over there for a little while.
Dude.
Like a,
you know,
the,
the wrestlers in Chechnya are amazing psyche of brothers,
the greatest ever.
Well fuck man.
If you grew up in Chechnya and it's like either be a standout wrestler or dead,
I don't know,
pick up a gun and you know,
be a gangster.
They,
you know,
Dude's amazing.
Yeah.
It's interesting to see a guy from that really hard part of the world coming
over and just dominating in MMA.
You know,
with Khabib,
you,
you know that a lot of it is technique.
A lot of is being trained by his father.
A lot of it is iron sharpens iron and he's at Aka,
he's wrestling with big giant guys that are really skillful all the time.
It's an amazing roster over there,
but a lot of it is his fucking mental toughness that he must've picked up some
of that from being in Dagestan.
Yeah,
it just has to,
it's true.
I mean,
the Russian fighters that I have,
I dealt with,
I'm like,
you could know them and call a ton of fights with them and they'll still kind of
look at you like they want to fight you or something.
Like,
you know,
I know that,
hey,
how's it going?
And then they kind of like break character like,
hey,
how you doing it?
But there's always this wall you've got to get through almost every time.
You know,
one of the great fighters on that,
uh,
Korskoff guy,
that guy's a fucking ball monster.
That guy's a beast.
That was one of the most impressive Lima fights to let me put that guy to sleep.
I was like,
Whoa,
yeah,
that left hook.
But it was a lake kicks.
It set it up.
He was kicking the shit out of that leg.
And He,
I think of course golf when like I got to trade now I've got to get this guy out
of here and you know,
it's not going to work.
And of course,
cough in my opinion in a lot of ways was one of the first guys to validate bell
tours.
Hundred 70 pound division from the performance he put against Henderson.
Like he shut Henderson down a t to harm teed off on them and let them know like
this is,
I am a real welterweight.
That when Numa made him look like maybe he's not,
maybe Lima's that's a real welterweight.
He's a lot bigger.
He looked bigger,
way bigger and then you know,
it's one of the things were that was a,
that was,
there was a big disparity between what people within the organization when
people out of the organization thought cause logical thought Henderson was going
to come in and clean house and have two belts.
But there's one jinx I that I have seen more than any other.
If you're listening fighters,
this is to,
you don't talk about two belts before you have one belt.
Ooh,
that is the chimps.
Have you never do it.
Am I wrong?
Brenda Vera with chain Vera.
I'm going to be two belt champion.
He didn't win one belt.
It's an innocent.
Talked about winning to bells and,
and when one belt,
you know,
talking about two belts before you've won one belt is a huge chunks.
Don't ever do that.
Well Ben never seen it be good.
I've seen a couple other times.
Never just never worked on when he left the UFC,
he was,
you know,
one of the best guys in the division and he got one of them three in this one 70
pound weight class was just not right for him.
With a big guy like Korskoff.
Yeah.
You know,
and it would have been more prominent if it was against Lima.
Did you see like they're weighing,
yeah,
I went to different,
so you know,
it's once these where we think about if a guy has trouble making 55 well he's a
70 no,
no,
he's not.
There's this needs,
there's a huge difference,
like a big 50 fiber and a natural 70 they are not in the same class.
In course cough.
It looked like a giant compared to,
well,
the difference is Lima's just not going to fucking make 55 it's just not half.
Not In his DNA.
If you can make the weight,
yeah.
Make the way I make the way.
Yeah.
It's a boy.
It's one of the most unfortunate parts of the sport and I like to back the cut
isn't tough then you shouldn't be there almost.
You know?
Like if you could make it easily,
you know,
it's tough man.
As long as it doesn't drain you because everybody's different too.
Right.
And their response to dehydration.
But Andy Foster what he's done in California by instituting a bunch of new
weight classes.
I really hope that people follow suit.
I really do.
I really hope there's one every 10 pounds.
I just think giving people more options,
it's going to,
there's some fighters that are just on the cusp where it's just dangerous,
you know?
And then maybe if they fought like dos Anjos goes up to 70 that's a but that's
at 55 to 70 15 pound jump.
That's a lot of weight,
man.
50% more than if it was just 10 and I think 10 is the move.
I feel like 10 every 10 you're not watering it down too much.
You making it reasonable.
Just Bang everything down to fives (556) 057-0580 five probably 95 two oh five
to 25 heavyweight.
So we were having a discussion with this.
Once again,
boxing.
I was talking to Steve for hood and I said when they initially,
initially weren't that many week class in boxing,
it ended up adding a bunch of them.
I said when they initially out of those,
were they seen as secondary weight classes?
And he went,
yeah,
yeah.
For it took years until one 55 got any respect.
It was considered people who couldn't hang at welterweight.
Put a big moment.
How about cruiserweight?
Yeah.
Cruiserweight never got response.
Never gets her splint.
Holy field fought Dwight Muhammad cow.
We,
there was a first time anybody give a fuck about cruiserweight.
Yep.
And who else was cruiserweight like who the fuck else was there?
White Mama Cow.
We cruiser.
[inaudible] John Pascale was,
um,
who else?
Michael Moore.
Did he stop at cruiserweight?
I think he went from light.
Hippolite damn,
you ain't,
I think you did too.
He did.
He didn't stop it comes to it.
Um,
just been one of those weird weight classes.
Like why not?
You're in prior fucking monstrous fighter,
but he fought at 40.
Right.
And just other than the Alexis Arguayo fight,
there weren't many stars at 40.
You've got to go to 47 to get paid.
There's a reason,
you know,
every talks about all Floyd can knock anybody out for,
it's like a fucking 35 or he's really a lightweight.
If you've ever met him,
he's not a big right.
He had to go to 47 to get the big money fights.
That's why,
you know Roberto Duran went from 35 to 47 cause he just couldn't make money at
35.
Yeah.
You guys get tired of making the way class,
but they also,
they realize like you got to chase the cat,
go where the money in a certain amount of time.
My Palm is Crawford moving up.
Yeah.
That's the problem is that it's very hard in MMA or any combat sport.
40 sevens,
Connie,
your limit below 47 went and had some great fighters.
It's hard to build interest below 47 or 45 in MMA.
Boxing has had the same problem.
So,
uh,
what happens,
people keep coming up.
So if you added a bunch of weight classes,
guys who wanted it one 60 for a while would be seen as all the guys who couldn't
make it at fit five seven.
Right.
So it would take awhile,
maybe a star in that division before it would become a legit division.
That'd be the prom.
There'd be a lag of a few years when you go all the one 80 pound champions.
Just the guy who couldn't,
couldn't do it at 17 it's almost like there's too many fighters now and too many
events.
It's almost like you couldn't have enough UFC events.
You would literally have to have UFC fights every week.
Yeah.
Like maybe that would be the future model where they have fights every week on
television and then they have paper views like rarely,
like every four weeks or something like that.
You would take a lot to fill up or six weeks,
four or five extra divisions.
That'd be tough.
You know,
it's hard to fill up the you have,
depending on how you look at it.
Yeah,
it would be,
but I mean,
man,
I don't know.
I mean,
I never get tired of watching fights.
If they had fights on every week,
I wouldn't be complaining.
It's just a wonder whether or not it's sustainable.
And I'm wondering what the hard part,
that's the hard part.
That's always been the hard part.
Um,
so I went to see something that is Novitsky is on tomorrow.
Right?
Um,
Jeff Dubitsky from uh,
you,
uh,
formerly of Usada now working for the UFC took me to the UFC performance
institute this week.
Holy fucking Shit,
man.
That place is insane.
I don't know how much money they spend on that,
but it's just like,
this is like some science lab for,
for training fighters.
I mean,
everything you could imagine they have in this giant ass bill heard every
fighter on the roster can go there anytime they want.
They have,
they,
they feed them,
they take care of them in the cafe.
They make them healthy food.
They have all these different things that monitor your body composition,
your hydration levels,
all these different modalities for healing and recovery,
everything.
You fucking name it,
they have it.
It was super impressive.
Super impressive.
They have all these video systems that are around the octagon constantly.
Their monitoring sparring from like a bunch of different angles.
They can get three d video of it.
They can rotate it.
Well they watch you spar from any angle.
Your coaches could point out little weird things that you might be doing that
you're not aware of but pointed out.
They always have the angle they get every single angle.
It's amazing.
They have a thing there that like punch registers,
you know?
Yeah.
Like the video game except a much more scientific.
Yeah,
there's little trivia.
You know I was told is the number one pound for pound punch her presence and
Ghana by by weight class?
No,
by weight class.
By weight class.
Like who's the number one for pound?
Just engaging.
That's what I was told.
Damp.
Yeah.
That's impressive.
Forrest Griffin told man,
I wonder how many people have punched it though.
I Dunno.
This is,
this is what I was told by by Forrest Griffin.
Well,
he certainly pushed as hard as fuck.
There's no doubt about it badly.
I mean in Gando,
just hard.
Anybody period blew it out of the water by some insane amount of thousands of
pounds a square inch.
They said he,
he's like drunk.
Whenever he hits,
he destroys bro.
He's,
they said he's like getting hit by an escort,
like a Ford escort.
That's what it's like.
Yeah.
I thought of a totally different escort for a second.
Yeah,
there it is.
They got a video of it,
of him hitting this thing that's a Dunkin French boom.
So they have them do this thing and they had this,
this limit before our,
or this record before that.
I actually I think was set by Tyrone Spong.
No surprise there.
He's an interesting fucking character,
Frances and gone and you want to talk about a guy that is literally right out of
an author's pen.
Really,
if you're going to have a guy who,
you know,
like robbery Howard,
when he used to write the Coney on books,
like he used to work in a sand mine.
He used to dig sand when he was a young man.
Like you watch fucking hard work.
It is digging in the sand every day and carrying it away and just getting
stronger and stronger.
It's literally like Quinn Conan was trashing the weekend mill.
Yeah.
And then he was homeless five years ago.
Moves to Paris,
wants to try boxing.
Someone sees him in a gym and goes,
Hey,
you should be an MMA.
And he's like,
okay.
So he goes into MMA,
goes to the UFC in two years he's fighting for the title and he's a big favorite
over the champion who is,
if the champion wins,
breaks the longest running title fight streak,
a winning title fights in the heavyweight division,
which is only two.
It's a great story.
It's amazing story story.
Five years ago,
homeless.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know Henry Armstrong,
I'm a great,
it was working on a railroad newspaper article about a guy winning a fight and
said fuck this railroad shit.
And went and started boxing one of the greatest of all time.
Yeah.
Or when Jack Johnson first became the heavyweight champion.
I mean everybody kind of knew,
you know,
he saw Jack Johnson like,
oh my God,
these guys are fucked.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's all downhill from here.
Yeah.
Him versus steep bays.
Very,
very interesting.
And I'm just,
I want to see if Steve Bay can figure out a way to avoid the big shots.
Close the distance,
get ahold of him and if he can take him to the ground.
Here's my advice for anybody calling that fight.
You went quid.
I would look at everything but power in terms of what,
who's got the better footwear?
Who's moving ahead a little bit more.
It was gonna more defense.
Cause man,
that's going to be,
I think tell the story.
One avoids getting hit and um,
cause they're both,
they can both knock you the fuck out.
Do.
They both can't to knock you the fuck out,
but
Francis doesn't in a weirder way.
He does it in,
they're like super human way where you're like,
we see the angle of his punches.
It's like he's trying to rip your soul out of your body,
man.
The left Hook uppercut combination punched that Shovel Hook was just one of the
most terrifying things I've ever seen anybody get hit with.
And all my years of calling sports look like a Pez dispenser had all the photos
so crazy.
It's almost like,
like a really bad action movie where the guy who's like the,
the guy was rising through the ranks and just blast to everybody in the orbit.
You,
you'll go to sleep,
even talks like those people.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Every now and then you get a story like that.
It seems like it's like Adam,
like Justin wren now that then your story is just ridiculous.
No,
he's amazing.
You know,
the,
um,
the other thing that about a in Ghana was the way he trashed talks is hilarious.
Like a steep,
a said a,
he's not intimidated by any man.
And,
uh,
Francisco's don't lies deeper.
Don't lie.
Like he's so calm with it and it's so fucking terrifying.
He was doing a press conference with Allister.
It was like a Thursday before Saturday is fight.
They're facing off wearing their suits and a Francisco's Saturday night to go to
sleep Saturday night you're asleep.
And
that tries talking bothers me.
He's so confident about it too.
And he was right.
But like Roy is like that.
Like,
yeah,
we'll take the bell and I will take your health.
Yeah.
And I'm holding the mic like,
Ooh,
Ooh,K
I want to hurt him so bad that he goes to the hospital,
never wants to fight me again.
And you go,
Oh gee,
that's shit either.
You know,
sometimes people talk shit and you know,
they're just trying to put up a bluff.
Yeah.
Like there's,
there's some,
even great fighters have said some shit that night.
I believed at the time,
like when Bj was saying to George,
Saint Pierre,
George,
we're going to fight to the death and I'm serious.
I'm going to try to kill you.
Remember that?
Yeah,
I remember it well.
Yeah.
That,
but it didn't work out.
That did not work out that way at all to not work out that way.
He might've believed that when he was saying it.
But man,
when you're in that dark,
dark moment,
big ass French Canadian dropping knuckle,
different world man.
Yeah.
That was another one where you're like,
there's a big gear.
Have seen a big 55 are in a real 70 dude cause he put it on him that night.
Well he was so fucking strong and George was in his prime back then and he also
was a really good guy and he was very motivated by Bj's talking shit to him and
really pissed him off because he's a nice guy,
you know.
I mean the best way to fight a guy like George is like be respectful.
If he's going to kick your ass gonna kick your ass anyway.
Yeah,
it's not a thing.
You can give him extra ass whooping motivation.
I think he had a little extra ass woke and motivation for Bisping though.
I really do.
Bisbing talks so much to him that when he got his back,
he's like,
you're going to put it on a man.
Put It on him,
put it on him,
standing up too much.
Just starting to wear down to just when I thought,
man,
maybe the tide storm,
because you don't Bisbing.
His whole thing is,
he's not a particularly hard puncher is wrestling.
You see great.
It's,
he wears you the fuck down.
Well that's big one 80 fiver.
No,
it's just he wears you the fuck down.
He's also particularly effective off of his back was,
I was impressed with that.
George up with those elbows off his back.
That made it a real problem because George is having a hard time seeing him and
that blood was everywhere.
Yeah.
You know what a good fight.
It's,
I kinda liked the story of George just retires.
It doesn't bother me.
Yeah.
I like it.
He bucked it,
he bucked there.
Everybody had doubted them.
Came back one one by finishes like,
yeah,
take it easy.
Now I'm out.
Say it now.
Now I'm seriously no,
really this time.
A minute.
Yeah.
Or it comes back in a year and one 55 and then what's but Whitaker,
Whitaker Rockhold for the title.
Yeah man,
that I liked that a lot.
I liked that five lot.
That's a dangerous ass fight for both guys.
Do you ever train with chuck today?
No Dude,
he was one of the first guys when I was a blue belt.
He came by and he was getting ready for Pan Ams and this is back when he was
like,
when he beat hoser at worlds,
broke his arm and still one like,
yeah,
that was insane.
Yeah,
that wasn't the same.
Would not tab,
wouldn't tat and wrote it out.
They change the rules after that.
You know that really?
Yeah,
because Jack Harry literally stuck is for people who are listening and don't
know about it.
He holds her Gracie broke Jackie Ray's arm and the the absolute division in the
world's 2005 2006 2004 around there,
mid 2000 and it snapped it good.
But Jocko,
he gets out like so.
He breaks it but he steps over the head and gets out.
Jack Arrays stands up and hold your look to the referee and goes,
I broke his arm and Jocko aid takes his broken arm,
stuffs it in his belt and wins the match because he was already ahead.
He just kinda like,
yeah,
you know,
stalled out for like two minutes and one the fucking match against the greatest
of all time with a broken arm.
So I trained with him and at that point he was like in beast mode.
It was unbelievable.
It's like being in a washing machine.
He's the only way I can describe it because once he grabs you,
it's like you're,
you just flings you and like your head,
you'll see your feet flying at the ceiling.
It's crazy now.
There it is,
man.
Yeah,
I remember this man.
I remember it.
He just snapped that fucking arm,
pulls it out and it is,
look at his left arm.
It is just,
just jacked.
Done man.
And he went out of bounds,
right?
And then he gets up and hold her at some point I think right there.
Tells a referee I his arm broken.
That's it.
And [inaudible] stuffs his broken arm in his,
in his belt and she's fine,
which is Beasley on,
he did a seminar at,
at uh,
at our place and a,
at the end he fought everybody in the room.
They're like 60 people there.
Wow.
And he fought everybody to everybody out.
Yeah.
In his prime,
in particularly in phenomenology who was unbelievably good.
And in MMA,
probably one of her district,
just two ever did he really beat holder beat for doom.
Wow.
He beat everybody.
Be Ted today.
He's one of my favorites.
I saw him live in Abu Dhabi too.
And like 2003.
Yup.
He lost two.
He lost to Salo in that year,
but he made the finals.
He beat high and Gracie and then he'd be Ricardo Almeida and then he lost to
Salo.
I remember that high and Gracie fight.
That was amazing.
And he was all online.
It was amazing too.
Yeah.
It was all over high.
Sallows and other guy that people forget about.
I love that guy.
Oh my God.
Love Him.
Him and his brother John Jay,
that,
that fucking smash style style.
That's where I'm from.
That's kind of like my,
you know,
I'm a Carlson guy and you know,
my instructors has got him,
Hey,
do yoga.
And he's always telling me,
he goes,
Jimmy Always,
oh,
this is the old people metaphors.
These like Jimmy,
he's like,
he was in Mario,
your God's Jim,
you'll finish is over for you.
Like,
don't like,
so he's always like,
Jamie,
I don't go as mount you,
Jimmy,
you fucking,
you fucking dumb man.
He Carlo border,
they'll take it back,
pull Hajime you'll finish.
That's another guy that I was asleep on his Laborio laboriel from,
from,
from what I have heard.
And you know,
obviously this is even before my time competitively,
he was the guy in the 90s,
like people who were around in that era,
like who was the guy?
And they're like,
hi,
Carla Lauria was the guy who was,
he was,
he took a world is the first year it happened.
It's interesting that these guys are still around still coaching MMA fighters,
you know,
still in the mix of the sport.
They have to be.
Yeah.
When you look at dayday pin an Eris,
uh,
her laborio both from the same team or both Carlson guys.
Listen guys,
we're a little boost to Montay hosts by Hato that you think about.
That was the first greasy team that had a real MMA team.
So those guys spread out and created so many teams tour a huge fee tour.
Yeah.
So what happens now with Timmy Smith?
Jimmy Smith's sits back until Jimmy Smith can make some sort of,
uh,
an announcement.
Yes.
That is what Jimmy Smith,
Jimmy Smith's got some pieces in motion though.
I have pieces in motion.
Maybe not.
Maybe we're just bullshitting you folks.
Could be.
Maybe because I'm working in Java juice next week,
but if fucked up Melatonin telling you you fucked up straight from Joe Rogan's
mouth made a mistake.
Well,
um,
you'll know more often my brain.
I know,
dude,
anytime you're in La Guy,
we've,
I'm an la guy.
It took me 20 minutes.
Just a ton of fights to talk about would definitely,
um,
I wish we could say more things folks,
but a,
you're going to figure it out anyway.
Jimmy Smith,
MMA on Twitter and on Instagram.
And,
uh,
I hope we worked together,
my friend.
Always a pleasure,
my brother.
Thank you very much,
very much.
And uh,
we'll be back tomorrow with the Golden Snitch,
Jeff Novitsky and,
uh,
and more.
Bye.